I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi! We're going to make a real splash today.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是好朋友。现在我们为您带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好！嗨！我们今天要搞点大动静。
A little splish splash. We're having a pool party. It is season 8 episode 12 written by Owen Ellixson. This was a new writer to our staff. This is his first episode and directed by… ACTION! Charles McDougall! Here is your summary.
溅起一点水花。我们要办个泳池派对。这是第八季第十二集，由欧文·埃利克森编剧。这是我们剧组的新编剧。这是他的第一集，导演是……动作！查尔斯·麦克道格尔！以下是剧情梗概。
In the midst of his divorce, Robert California throws a pool party for his employees at his soon-to-be sold house. Meanwhile, Jim tries to sneak out early and Aaron enlists Dwight to flirt with her to try to make Andy jealous. Oh, my goodness. The cringe factor on their flirting was, I don't know, DefCon 5. Fast fact number one today is a location breakdown. We got a lot of fan mail about this crazy house and DC from Durham, North Carolina, who said this house is incredible, is it real? And from Sarah in
罗伯特·加利福尼亚正值离婚之际，在他即将被售出的豪宅里为员工们举办了一场泳池派对。与此同时，吉姆试图早退，艾琳则让德怀特去和她调情，以此试图让安迪吃醋。哦，天哪。他们调情时的尴尬指数，我不知道，简直是最高防御级别（DefCon 5）。今天的第一个趣味事实是关于取景地的盘点。我们收到了很多关于这座位于华盛顿特区附近、极其疯狂的房子的粉丝来信，来自北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的粉丝说这房子太不可思议了，它是真的吗？还有来自
Kingwood, Texas, who said, was each room shown, including the pool, all one house and location? Thanks for your questions. We got all the deets. We did. Jenna reached out to Steve Burgess, and I reached out to Matt Flynn. Steve Burgess said that pool party was one of the most complicated and expensive episodes we ever shot of the office, and it all came down to locations. Steve said they spent 12 hours driving around in a van, looking at different houses with swimming pools,
德克萨斯州金伍德的萨拉说，展示的每个房间，包括泳池，全都是同一栋房子和同一个取景地吗？谢谢你们的问题。我们拿到了所有细节。确实如此。珍娜联系了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我联系了马特·弗林。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，那个泳池派对是我们在《办公室》拍过最复杂、最昂贵的单集之一，这一切都归结于取景地。史蒂夫说他们花 了 12 个小时开着面包车四处寻找带有游泳池的不同房子，
and they could not find one that worked. So they ended up renting two different houses, one for when they go on the house tour and one for the swimming scenes. Yes, I went to the house for the swimming scenes. I didn't do the tour. You know, Angela Martin doesn't go on the tour. So I have my own personal stories. I'm going to share about that house. But Matt Flynn, who was now our production designer, he shared some great nuggets, lady. OK. First of all, he said the script called for very specific things, that the character of James Spader was extremely wealthy and somewhat mysterious and should have a grand residence,
却找不到一个合适的。所以他们最后租了两栋不同的房子，一栋用于参观房屋的场景，一栋用于游泳的场景。是的，我去了拍游泳场景的那栋房子。我没去参观。你知道的，安吉拉·马丁没有去参观。所以我也有关于那栋房子的个人故事要分享。但是马特·弗林，也就是我们当时的艺术指导，他分享了一些很棒的幕后花絮，女士。好的。首先，他说剧本要求非常具体，詹姆斯·斯派德的角色极其富有且带有一点神秘色彩，应该拥有一处宏伟的住宅，
which included an indoor pool as one might find around Scranton, Pennsylvania. And then his email to me, he said, so let's start there. Locations scoured San Fernando Valley, like Steve said. It was very hard to meet all these demands. And then they heard about this house off of Mahal and Drive that was owned by a famous sports legend that had an indoor pool. They were like, this is gonna check all the boxes.
其中包括宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿附近可能会有的室内泳池。然后他在给我的电子邮件里说，那我们就从这里开始吧。像史蒂夫说的那样，取景地搜遍了圣费尔南多谷。要满足所有这些要求非常难。然后他们听说在马哈兰大道附近有一栋由某位著名体育传奇人物拥有的房子，里面有一个室内泳池。他们当时想，这下所有条件都符合了。
It was not available. And they made multiple offers over and over again, and they said, no. Wow. So they had to continue their search. Well, eventually they found two houses, and FastFac number two is a breakdown of those houses. So let's start with the one they used for the house on the tour. This was shot at a real house in in Sino, California.
结果那栋房子不对外开放。他们一次又一次地反复出价，而对方都拒绝了。哇。所以他们只能继续寻找。好吧，最终他们找到了两栋房子，第二个趣味事实就是这两栋房子的详细解析。所以我们先从他们用来拍摄参观房子的那一栋开始。这其实是在加州恩西诺的一处真实住宅里拍摄的。
Steve Burgess said the houses on the street were all incredible. The Jackson family had a house. Yeah. It was like one block away from this house. But we took out the owner's real furniture and we put in our own. Steve said the furniture was like so expensive, we could not afford to mess up their real furniture. We added all of the neon that was in the media room,
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，那条街上的房子都不可思议。杰克逊家族就在那里有一栋房子。是的。离这栋房子只有一个街区远。但我们把房东真正的家具搬走了，换上了我们自己的。史蒂夫说那家具太贵了，我们可承担不起弄坏他们真家具的代价。我们添加了媒体室里所有的霓虹灯，
that was us. And I guess there was a giant painting like the size of an entire wall. Steve sent me a picture of it and we couldn't remove it. So we had to rope it off so that we didn't damage it. It looks like a museum, like how you rope things off in a museum.
那都是我们弄的。而且我想那里有一幅整面墙那么大的巨型画作。史蒂夫给我发了一张照片，我们根本取不下来。所以我们只好用绳子把它围起来，以免损坏它。看起来就像个博物馆，就像你在博物馆里用绳子把展品围起来那样。
I guess this painting was worth a fortune. There was also an outdoor pool at this house. It was in the backyard and we had to avoid showing it out any of the windows so that it wouldn't ruin the story that Robert had an indoor pool. Yes, Matt said this in Sino House was a fantastic 1980s era mansion. He said it had a brutalist design, a sophisticated and elegant board-poured concrete residence offset with panels of smooth
我猜这幅画价值连城。这栋房子外面其实也有一个露天泳池。它在后院，我们必须避免从任何窗户拍到它，以免破坏罗伯特拥有室内泳池的设定。是的，马特说这栋恩西诺的房子是一座极具八十年代风格的奇妙豪宅。他说它有着粗野主义的设计，是一处精致优雅的现浇混凝土住宅，点缀着光滑的威尼斯抹灰板面和其他高端元素，但就是没有室内泳池。有泳池的那栋房子在南帕萨迪纳，但问题是，它也不是一个室内泳池。有泳池的那栋房子在南帕萨迪纳。但问题是，它也没有室内泳池。它有点像室内室外结合的泳池。是的。史蒂夫也给我发了这张照片。它差不多就是一半露天，有一个通向它的大门，是一个半室内的泳池区域。
veneetian plaster panels and other high-end elements, but no indoor pool. The house with the pool was in South Pasadena, but here's the thing, it also was not an indoor pool. The house with the pool was in South Pasadena. But here's the thing, it also was not an indoor pool. It was sort of like an indoor outdoor pool. Yes. Steve sent me a picture of this as well. And it was sort of like half outdoors with a big door that led to it, a partial indoor pool area.
所以他说我们的剧组搭建了一堆假墙，以便把整个泳池封闭起来。这花了整整三天，每天24小时。我们还得铺设一套复杂的电网，以便能够照亮这个房间。史蒂夫说每盏灯都安装了一种叫防触电保护器（shock blocker）的东西，这样即使有东西掉进泳池，也能在任何人受伤之前切断电源。但这可是一项巨大的建筑工程。
So he said that our crews built a bunch of fake walls in order to enclose the whole pool. It took like 24 hours a day for three days. We also had to lay down a complicated electrical grid so that we could light the room. Steve said every light had something called a shock blocker so that we could light the room. Steve said every light had something called a shock blocker so that if something fell in the pool it would cut off power before anyone got hurt. But this was a massive construction job.
巨大。好吧，我有一些从这一集中拍摄的照片，我会分享到我们的动态里。我拍的一张照片就是大家聚在一起闲聊，你能看到我们在拍摄时不得不绕着泳池放置的所有灯光。它们就在泳池旁边。所以，是的，幸亏他们有那个，叫什么来着？防触电保护器。对，防触电保护器。
Massive. Okay, so I have some photos I took from this episode that I will share in our stories. One photo I took is just everyone hanging out and you can see all the lights that they had to put around the pool when we were filming. They are right next to the pool. So yeah, it's a good thing they had that, what were they called? Shock blockers. Yeah, the shock blockers.
马特是这样评价帕萨迪纳那栋房子的，顺便说一句，它距离恩西诺的房子有30英里远。所以想象一下两头跑有多折腾。他说这栋房子非常壮观。它建于20世纪60年代，拥有蒙德里安式的色彩搭配。他说这两栋房子在各方面都不搭。哦，天哪。所以他们必须决定想要哪种房屋外观。他们选择了恩西诺那栋房子的外观，然后
Here's what Matt said about the Pasadena house, which by the way was 30 miles away from the Encino house. So imagine the back and forth. He said this house was spectacular. It was built in the 1960s and had a Mondrian color palette. He said these two houses did not match in any way. Oh my gosh. So they had to decide which look of the house they wanted. They picked the look of the Encino House and then they
必须把这种设计融入到帕萨迪纳的房子里。这包括用类似于现浇混凝土的墙面以及与恩西诺房子相同的威尼斯嵌板，将所有现有的室内表面全部包覆起来。所有这一切必须在一周内完成。这太疯狂了。太疯狂了。而且他说帕萨迪纳对于任何打扰他们所谓的“塑料环境”的制作公司都有非常严格的规定。我知道这一点，因为我们以前在帕萨迪纳的一栋房子里拍摄过《分道扬镳》（Splitting Up Together），他们对于你什么时候可以进入和离开社区有着非常严格的规定。是的。他们称之为尾灯熄灭（tail lights out）。意思就是晚上10点前我得看见你的车尾灯开走。
had to incorporate that design onto the Pasadena House. That included cladding all the existing interior surfaces with walls that resembled the board poured concrete and the same Venetian panels from the Encino House. And all of this had to happen within one week. That is bonkers. Bonkers. And he said Pasadena has very strict rules regarding any production company interrupting their quote, plastic environment. I know this because we used to shoot splitting up together at a house in Pasadena and they have very strict rules about when you can enter and leave neighborhoods. Yes. They call it tail lights out. That means I need to see your tail lights leaving as of 10 p.m.
他说所有的施工人员都翻倍了。他们把施工人员的规模扩大了一倍来应对这个挑战。他说，原话是，“这简直是一团糟（cluster F）。”但我们工作的时间非常有限。并且他说帕萨迪纳的那个社区有各种停车限制。我也记得那个。所以我记得这件事，是因为我们的演员房车停得很远，我们必须坐摆渡车来回，剧组人员也是。他们把我们的房车停在一个购物中心，距离这个社区有一段相当远的距离。
He said all the construction crews were doubled. They doubled the size of the crews to meet this challenge. He said, and I quote, it was a real cluster F. But we had such limited hours to work. And he said there were all of these parking restrictions in Pasadena in the neighborhood. I remember that too. So I remember this because our trailers were very far away and we had to be shuttle back and forth and so did the crews. They parked our trailers at a shopping center, like a good distance from this neighborhood.
是的，他们对在社区里停放房车有规定，比如演员更衣室、房车和大卡车。马特想向建筑工人、布景画家和布景装饰团队致以谢意，因为他说他们绝对是各自领域的行家，为这一集极其古怪的剧集呈现了一个华丽完美的最终环境。当时有人告诉他，单单这一集的施工成本就超过了前三到四季的总和。是的。马特说他也非常感谢本集导演查尔斯·麦克道格尔的支持。他说杀青后，查尔斯送了他一瓶极好的红酒和一张卡片，上面写着：“我们本来根本没资格把这一集在
Yes, they have rules about parking trailers in neighborhoods, like cast, changing rooms, and trailers, and big trucks. Matt wanted to give a shout out to the construction, scenic painters, and set decorating crews because he said they were absolute masters at their game and produced a glorious finished environment for this particularly quirky episode. He was told at the time this single episodes constructions costs were more than the first three or four seasons cost combined. Yes. Matt said he's also been very grateful to the episodes director Charles McDougal for his support. He said once they wrapped, Charles gave him a very fine bottle of wine and a card which read, we had no right to be able to get this episode shot
上周拍完。你对取景地的选择非常正确，设计得也极其精妙。非常感谢你出色的工作。”那是查尔斯·麦克道格尔。那是查尔斯·麦克道格尔。那是查尔斯·麦克道格尔。他对你要求严格，但他很赏识你。
last week. You made the right call on the locations and designed them brilliantly. Thanks so much for all of the good work. That's Charles McDougall. That's Charles McDougall. That's Charles McDougall. He works your hard, but he appreciates you.
他确实如此。好吧，接下来是第三个趣味事实，我给它起名叫“最尴尬的一集”。你刚才提到了这个，安吉拉。其实我们收到了大量关于这个话题的粉丝来信。我来读一读来自密西西比州橄榄枝镇的梅洛迪·S的信，她说：“我在办公室上班，我在想，如果让我和所有平时只能在办公室见到的同事们一起穿着泳衣，会有多尴尬。
He sure does. Well, next up is Fast Fact 3, which I titled Cringiest Episode. You brought this up earlier Angela. We got a fan mail flurry on this topic actually. I'm gonna read one from Melody S in Olive Branch, Mississippi, who said, I work in an office and thought how awkward it would be
对每个人来说，在同事面前穿着泳衣不是很诡异又尴尬吗？”对！确实很尴尬！我的意思是，我们又不是《海滩救护队》的演员！好吧，行吧！《海滩救护队》，第一天就把我招了吧！我和你一起穿泳衣。那就是我们的制服。那就是我们穿的。我从第一天起就知道你穿泳衣长什么样了。
for me to be in the bathing suit with all of my coworkers who I only see at the office. Was it weird and awkward for everyone to be in bathing suits in front of their co-workers? Yes! Yes it was! I mean, we weren't the cast of Baywatch! Okay, fine! Baywatch, you hire me day one! I'm in a bathing suit with you. That's our outfit. That's what we wear. I know what you look like in a bathing suit from day one.
在纸业公司工作可不是这情况。所以，你知道的，我曾就这一集和埃莉·肯珀发信息交流，她发来了一些音频剪辑，而她发来的第一段音频，甚至在我还没问她这个问题之前，就谈到了这个话题。我们来听听。谈的是这个话题吗？对，我们听听。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。我是埃莉。好吧，我对《泳池派对》这一集有些想法。首先，我超级喜欢那一集。我不知道你们是不是，但我太喜欢实地外景拍摄了。
Not the case when you work at a paper company. So, you know, I was trading messages with Ellie Kemper about this episode and she sent in some audio clips and the first one that she sent in without me even asking her this question was on this topic. Let's listen. What was on this topic? Yeah, let's listen. Hi, Jenna and Angela. This is Ellie. Okay, I have some thoughts about pool party. First of all, I loved that episode. I don't know if you did, but I loved being on location.
我非常确定我们是在某个人的真房子里拍的，对吧？里面还有一个室内泳池。所以那真的超级有趣。我要告诉你们，我不知道你们是不是也有同样的反应，但当我们在前一周进行剧本围读时，我们发现大家得连续一周都穿着泳衣。他们只提前了大约五天通知我们，给了五天心理准备。好吧，准备好穿泳衣吧。我当时慌了，因为那感觉就像是，我相当确定当时是，我不知道，冬天。那可不是你会觉得“哦，我要穿着泳衣去海滩”的季节。
I'm pretty sure we were in someone's actual house, right? With an indoor pool. So that was a ton of fun. I will tell you, I don't know if you had a similar reaction, but when we did the table read the week before we found out we all had to be in swimsuits for a week. They gave us like five days notice, five days heads up. Okay, be swimsuit ready. I panicked because it was like, I'm pretty sure it was, I don't know, winter. It was not a time where you were thinking, oh, I'm going gonna be out on the beach in a swimsuit.
所以我记得我连续三天做了俯卧撑，然后就停了。总之，这就让我做好了穿泳衣的准备。是的，我的意思是，这太疯狂了，简直离谱。就像，如果你去拍电影，你会想：这就是这部电影对我所有的要求。但当你拍电视剧时，你是在拍摄前一周才知道下一周对你有什么要求的。
So I remember for three days, I did push-ups and then stopped. Anyway, so that got me swimsuit ready. Yes, I mean, that's bonkers, that's something. Like, if you do a movie, you're like, here's everything that's gonna be required of me for this movie. But when you're on a TV show, you learn everything that's gonna be required of me for this movie. But when you're on a TV show, you learn the week before what's required of you the next week.
对。所以根本没有准备时间。我的意思是，我们后面会聊到。我得在泳衣里面戴一个假的孕肚。我待会儿会细说。好吧。你知道的，网上有那么多关于《办公室》最尴尬剧集的盘点，
Yeah. So there's no prep time. I mean, we'll get into it. I had to wear a fake Pregor's belly in a bathing suit. I'm gonna get into it later. Okay. Well, you know, there are so many lists of the cringiest office episodes
而《泳池派对》从来没上过榜。不过，我必须说，看完这一集后，它在我心里的尴尬榜直接飙升到了第一名。我想在此之前，榜首可能是《王子家族纸业》。我觉得《花园派对》也挺尴尬的。我的意思是，《斯科特的小茨》在我心里的排名都在下降。这可真说明问题了。我懂。我对这一集的尴尬程度感同身受。
and Pool Party never makes the list. However, I have to say after watching it, this one has moved to the top of the list for me. I think before this, it was maybe Prince Family Paper. I found Garden Party quite cringy. I mean, Scott's tots is moving down the list for me. That's saying something. I know. I'm with you in the cringe factor on this one.
有几个瞬间我都觉得：等等，什么鬼？我怎么不记得发生过这事。我在 cheat sheet.com 上找到了一篇文章，标题是《办公室粉丝对泳池派对的看法》。这篇文章是在这一集播出后发布的。我猜是 NBC 的《办公室》官方 Instagram 账号发布了《泳池派对》的一个片段，
There's a few moments that I was like, wait, what? I forgot happened. I found an article on cheat sheet.com titled, How the Office Fans Feel About Pull Party. And it came out after this episode was released. I guess NBC's The Office Instagram had posted a clip from Pull Party,
粉丝们迅速涌入评论区，将这一集评为《办公室》历史上最诡异的一集。好吧。其中一条评论写道：这一集简直是……无话可说。我们就点到为止吧。我觉得这总结得很到位。这评价挺高。你知道的，关于这一集我有个坦白。这是我第一次看它。它播出的时候我没看。哦，真的吗？
and fans quickly took to the comments to name the episode the weirdest office episode in history. Okay. One comment read, this episode was dot dot dot, it was. Let's just leave it at that. I think that sums it up. That's pretty good. You know, I have a confession about this episode. This was my first time watching it. I did not watch it when it aired. Oh, yeah.
是的，我这是生平第一次体验到那种“无语凝噎”的感觉。它真的太尴尬了。我懂。你知道的，我读过剧本初稿。他们甚至在我产假期间还把稿子发给我了。而且你知道吗，其实我当时主动提出想给这一集打个电话客串一下。我想象吉姆和帕姆可以通个电话，比如当吉姆试图离开罗伯特的房子时。
Yeah, I experienced the dot, dot, dot for the very first time. It is truly cringey. I know. You know, I had read the table draft. They still sent it to me on my maternity leave. And you know, I actually offered to call in for this episode. I thought Jim and Pam could have a phone call, like maybe when Jim is trying to leave Robert's house.
对，就像帕姆说：嘿，你在哪儿呢？对，你什么时候回家？我以为那会给他施加更多压力，但电视台拒绝了。剧组说他们不允许我打电话客串。不，因为那样他们就得付我片酬。哦，也对。但你不觉得那样会很好吗？
Yeah, like Pam's like, hey, where are you at? Yes, when are you gonna get home? I thought that would put more pressure on him, but the network said no. It says they said you couldn't call in. No, cause then they'd have to pay me. Oh, yeah. But don't you think that would have been good?
我也觉得。我真该参与的，总比这集里完全没有帕姆要好，不过算了。但他们就是没采纳。我本来挺希望这集里能有帕姆的戏份的。非常感谢。我也这么觉得。好吧，也许我们该进广告了。
I do. I should have, instead of just having no Pam in this episode, I don't know. But no, they didn't go for it. I would have liked some Pam in this episode. Thank you very much. I think so too. Well, maybe we should go to break.
然后我们回来聊聊我生平第一次看的这一集。好的。我们回来了。这一集以一个……呃，吉姆的恶作剧开场，但这里真正被恶作剧的人到底是谁？没错。德怀特回到办公桌前，当他意识到自己坐在了一块肉丸上时，他整个人都恶心坏了。对，斯坦利觉得这 hilarious（太搞笑了）。然后吉姆分享说，没有了帕姆，他恶作剧德怀特时都没什么观众了，这乐趣少了一半，直到他发现了斯坦利。
And then we'll come back and talk about this episode that I watched for the very first time. Okay. We are back. This episode kicks off with a, um, Jim prank, but who's really being pranked here? Yes. Dwight returns to his desk and he is disgusted when he realizes he's sat on a meatball. Yeah, Stanley thinks that's hilarious. And then Jim shares that without Pam, he doesn't really have an audience for his pranking of Dwight, and that was half the fun, until he found Stanley.
然而，斯坦利的品味非常非常独特。我们看到了一段各种恶作剧的混剪，而能让斯坦利笑出声的东西只有一样，那就是：被肉丸砸了。天哪，技术。中肉丸了。好吧，我们发现的情况基本上是，吉姆已经连续好几周在喂德怀特和斯坦利了。这个肉丸恶作剧，我的意思是，他到底哪来美国时间？话说回来，当吉姆带了36个肉丸去公司并把它们塞进德怀特的抽屉里时，帕姆在家里是怎么说的？
However, Stanley has very, very specific taste. We see a little montage of a variety of pranks and there's only one thing that makes Stanley laugh and that is, be in meatballed. Gosh, tech. Got meatballed. Well, what we find out is basically Jim has been feeding Dwight and Stanley for weeks. This meatball prank, I mean, when does he have the time? What is, by the way, Pam saying at home, when Jim brings 36 meatballs to work and puts
我们永远不会知道了，因为我根本没参演这一集。哦，这个梗会一直回旋的，各位。实话告诉你们吧，我们在那个混剪里看到的其中一个恶作剧，是一张用乐高拼成的办公桌。菲尔·谢伊让人制作了那张桌子。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说它极其脆弱。确实如此。我们根本不能靠近它，也不能碰它，否则它会立刻散架。
him in Dwight's drawer, we'll never know because I wasn't in the episode. Oh, it's going to keep coming back, guys. I'll have you know, one of the pranks we saw in that montage was a desk made out of Lego. Phil Shea had that desk made. Steve Burgess said it was very delicate. It was. We could not get near it or touch it or it would fall apart immediately.
对，你真的什么都不能放在上面。你甚至可以在剧集里看到它往下塌陷。是的。菲尔还负责所有的肉丸，以及把一个订书机塞进一个巨型肉丸里。我真的很想看看菲尔·谢伊在读完一集剧本后的待办清单。你能想象在街上捡到一张吗？你见过那些叫作“失物”之类的书吗？里面全都是
Yeah, you couldn't really set anything on it. You can even see in the episode it dips down. Yes. Phil was also in charge of all the meatballs and putting a stapler into a giant meatball. I really want to see fill Shay's to-do lists after he reads an episode. Could you imagine finding one on the street? Have you seen those books they're called like found? And they're just
诸如此类的碎片，比如可能是某人的购物清单，或者某人的收据。我太想看一份菲尔·谢伊的清单了。亲爱的，你今天在公司干了什么？嗯，我把一个订书机塞进了一大包肉里，然后我试图想办法在不融化订书机的情况下把它烤熟。太疯狂了。你知道的，这个冷开场以这几个家伙站在停车场里结束，他们兴奋得不行，因为他们有免费肉丸吃，而且正在大快朵颐。我当时觉得恶心透了，因为我在想：
like snippets of like maybe it's like someone's grocery list or it's like someone's receipt. I would love to see a fill-shay list. Honey, would you do it work today? Um, I put a stapler and a giant pack of meat, then I tried to figure out how to bake it without melting the stapler. So crazy. You know, this cold open ends with these guys standing in the parking lot and they're so excited because they're getting free meatballs and they're eating them. I was grossed out by it because I was like,
那些肉丸还能吃吗？它们可一直在办公桌抽屉里啊。所以你想吃一个别人坐过的肉丸吗？另外，根据玛莎·斯图尔特（Martha Stewart）和美国农业部的说法，易腐食品（包括熟肉）在室温下放置的最大安全时间是两小时。在此之后它就不再安全可食用了，把它装进塑料袋里也无济于事。所以我真的希望当时没有过去两个多小时，否则这几个家伙待会儿要在马桶上度过一段非常“精彩”的时光了。
are those meatballs still edible? They've been in like a desk drawer. So do you want to eat a meatball, someone's sat on? Also, according to Martha Stewart and the US Department of Agriculture, the maximum amount of time that a perishable food, including a cooked meat, should sit out, is two hours. After that it's no longer safe to eat and it doesn't even matter if you put it in a plastic bag. So I really hope that like more than two hours didn't pass or those guys are
这或许能解释我在大学里某一两次糟糕的早晨。对啊。我们以前会把披萨直接留在盒子里放在外面。你可千万别这么干。然后第二天早上我还会拿它当早餐吃。不。不，我们可不能那样。哦，天哪。节目一开始是艾琳在前台接待处。她接到了一个电话。是杰西卡打来的。然后艾琳有一个独白，她在里面说，你知道吗？她可不是那种无法释怀的前任。她有自己的生活，他们有他们的生活。她正在上意大利语课，这基本上就是指她一直在吃意大利美食。她甚至对杰西卡说，你知道吗？你今天听起来声音挺好听的。 yeah. 哦，艾琳。然后他有一个独白，他在里面
gonna have like a real exciting time on the toilet later. This might explain one or two mornings for me at college. Yeah. We used to leave pizza out like in the box. You shouldn't do that. And then the next morning I would have it for breakfast. No. No, we can't do that. Oh, Lord. The show starts with Erin at Front Reception. She's going to get a phone call. It's Jessica. And Erin's going to have a talking head where she says, you know what? She's not going to be one of those X's who can't move on. She's got her life. They have theirs. She's taking Italian class, which is basically her just eating Italian food. And she even says to Jessica, you know what? You sound pretty today. Yeah. Oh, Aaron. And he's going to have a talking head where
透露说杰西卡见过他的父母了，他们非常喜欢她，以至于把这枚家族戒指给了他，让他去求婚。我的意思是，他都好几年没订婚了。我太喜欢这句台词了。不过中间的钻石不见了。嗯，他的父母觉得这颗钻石更适合他弟弟。我们收到了一条来自马来西亚的阿德里娜·A的粉丝提问，她说：“安吉拉·阿伯特（Angel Abbot），尊贵的女士，用她从Ebay上卖掉安迪订婚戒指得到的钱买的……但现在在《泳池派对》里，安迪不知怎么又把戒指拿回来了，我太糊涂了。”
he reveals that Jessica met his parents and they liked her so much, they gave him this family ring so he can propose. I mean, he hasn't been engaged in years. I love that line. It's missing the center diamond though. Well, his parents thought that was better for his brother. We got a fan question from Adrina A. in Malaysia who said, Angel Abbot, Princess Lady with the money she got
安吉拉，我必须说，我们收到了很多关于这个的粉丝来信，这确实让人很困惑，但安吉拉卖掉的那枚戒指完全是另一回事，对吧？你拿到的可不是什么家族传家宝。没有，安吉拉可没拿到家族传家宝。
from selling Andy's engagement ring on eBay, but now in Pool Party, Andy somehow got the ring back, I'm so confused. Angela, I have to say, we got a lot of fan mail about this, this was very confusing to people, but the ring that Angela sold is totally different, right? You didn't get a family heirloom. No, Angela did not get the family heirloom.
也许安迪的父母没那么喜欢她，所以才不肯给。安迪给我的那枚戒指是祖母绿切割的。对。而这枚是个带有大主石的椭圆形戒指。所以，不是同一枚戒指。很高兴能为观众们澄清这一点。我们为此收到了大量邮件。是的，但是你知道吗？在《花园派对》之后，我们都知道安迪父母的喜爱对意味着什么。所以他们喜欢杰西卡到甚至愿意把这枚戒指给他的程度，我觉得安迪这次绝对要尘埃落定、把她套牢了。
Maybe Andy's parents didn't like her that much to give it up. The ring Andy gave me was like an emerald cut. Yeah. This is like an oval ring with a big center piece. So no, not the same ring. I'm glad we could clear that up for people. We got a lot of mail about it. Yes, but you know what? We all know after Garden Party, what the favor of Andy's parents means to him. So the fact that they like Jessica, enough to even give him this ring, I feel like Andy's gonna lock it down.
女士，我挺喜欢杰西卡的。我喜欢杰西卡。我喜欢安迪和杰西卡在一起时的状态。我也是。我现在可不支持安迪和艾琳复合。我也是。也许我本该支持他们，但我觉得杰西卡太棒了。我挺喜欢他们俩在一起的。
Lady, I like Jessica. I like Jessica. I like who Andy is when he's with Jessica. Me too. I am not rooting for Andy and Aaron right now. Me either. Maybe I'm supposed to be, but I think Jessica's fantastic. I like them together.
我也是。我一直在想要怎么把他们的名字结合在一起。你知道大家是怎么做的吗？比如有“德安吉拉”（Duangela）。对，这个很难组合。对。还有杰西卡，也许这就是他们不能在一起的原因？因为“安丹”（Andan）听起来挺顺口。
Me too. I was trying to think of how to combine their names. You know how people do that? There's Duangela. Yeah, it's a hard one. Yeah. And Jessica, maybe this is why they can't be together. Cause Andan works.
安迪和艾琳。“安丹”确实行得通。“德安吉拉”行得通。“杰米和艾琳”。“安丁”也行得通。“德温杰洛”行得通。“杰米”。“杰米”。如果你们的名字要被组合在一起，这也是某种恋爱关系测试吗？我不知道。好吧，罗伯特·加利福尼亚正在网上看一栋房子，吉姆、
Andy and Aaron. Andan does work. Duangela works. Jam and Aaron. And Andin does work. Dwayngelo works. Jam. Jam. Is this a relationship test if your name is going to be combined? I don't know. Well, Robert California is looking at a house online and Jim and
奥斯卡和德怀特对它评头论足。他们觉得这房子实在太大、太夸张了。对，吉姆说它有一种《闪灵》的阴森气质。我喜欢当他们对这栋俗气的房子大加吐槽时，罗伯特却说：“我正考虑把它卖了。”这是一个很棒的反转。电脑屏幕上显示的是这些：如果你和珍娜跟我一样，你可能也会放大看那个雷马克（Remax）的房源信息。
Oscar and Dwight are really judging it. They just think it's too big too much. Yeah, Jim says it has the shining energy to it. I love while they're just going off on this tacky house. He says, I'm thinking of selling it. He's a great reveal. Here is what the computer screen said. If you were like Jen and I, you probably zoomed in on that remax listing. Yes, that's right. It has six bedrooms and eight bathrooms. It's $6,749,000. It is 11,325 square feet on the inside,
是的，没错。它有6间卧室和8个卫生间。售价是 6,749,000 美元。它的室内面积为 11,325 平方英尺，
and it is on a 26,710 square foot lot, which is a little over half an acre. It's also already been on the market 42 days. He's sweating it. He's sweating it. That's why he's going to have to have it staged. You guys know about houses getting staged, right? I mean, if you've ever watched House Hunters or any like home selling show or like property brothers.
占地面积为 26,710 平方英尺，稍微超过半英亩。而且它已经在市场上挂牌 42 天了。他急得出汗了。他急得出汗了。这就是为什么他必须找人把房子做“房屋布景陈设（staged）”。你们知道房子要做布景陈设这回事吧？我的意思是，如果你看过《买房记》（House Hunters）或者任何诸如此类的卖房节目，或者像《房产兄弟》（Property Brothers）。
I didn't know about this until I started to look for house, you know, to buy. And you would go in and there would be like a fakey bedroom setup and I sat on the bed, went home and it was like cardboard. And I was like, what the heck? What are these people? And I pulled back the, and it was like cardboard, and I was like, what the heck? What are these people? And I pulled back the covers, and it was like a big old box,
我直到开始找要买的房子时才知道这回事。然后你走进去，会看到一个假惺惺的卧室布景，我坐在床上，回家后发现那是纸板做的。当时我就想：搞什么鬼？这些人到底……我掀开床单，发现那其实是个大纸盒箱，
and I was like, what is happening? And then the rilter explained to me. But I guess there's a whole thing. People need to see how the space can be used, and a lot of times people put their house up for sale, don't stage it, and it sits on the market. So I thought it was a nice little detail that it had been on the market
当时我就震惊了：这到底是怎么回事？然后中介向我解释了。但我猜这里面有一整套学问。人们需要看到这个空间可以怎么被利用，很多时候人们把房子挂牌出售时不做房屋布景陈设，房子就会一直滞销。所以我认为这是一个很棒的小细节，它已经在市场上挂牌了
42 days and then Robert decides to have this last hurrah before the staging folks from Remax come. These are dorky things I get excited about. I'm like that's true! He probably didn't need it stage. It's kind of a weird looking house. It also says the address is 2374 Oakview Road in Scranton. I looked it up. That doesn't exist. I mean, I hope not. Well, I know for those point. I know. Robert explains that he bought this whole mansion because it was going to be like his playboy mansion. He bought it after watching Eyes Wide Shut, I guess. And then he met his wife who completely changed it. Now she's left and he asked to sell it. They're even calling his speakeasy lounge a rumpus room.
42天，然后罗伯特决定在雷马克的布景人员到来之前举办最后一场狂欢。这些都是让我兴奋的小众宅男细节。我就觉得：太真实了！他可能确实不需要做布景。这房子看起来确实挺怪异的。上面还写着地址是斯克兰顿的奥克维路（Oakview Road）2374号。我查过了。根本没有这个地址。我是说，希望没有吧。好吧，我知道……我懂。罗伯特解释说他买下整栋豪宅是因为它本来要被打造成他的花花公子豪宅。我猜他是在看完《大开眼戒》（Eyes Wide Shut）后买的。然后他遇到了彻底改变了这里的妻子。现在她离家出走了，他不得不把房子卖掉。他们甚至把他的地下酒吧休息室叫作“喧闹娱乐室（rumpus room）”。
Jim, chuckles. And oh my gosh. You remember in Gettysburg, when Andy calls Jim out for being a snarky smart ass? Robert is about to do the same. Here's how it shakes down. Jim chuckles at Robert, and Robert is not having it.
吉姆轻笑了一声。哦，天哪。还记得在《葛底斯堡》那一集里，安迪当众指责吉姆是个爱挖苦人的聪明鬼吗？罗伯特马上也要这么干了。事情是这样的。吉姆对罗伯特发出轻笑，而罗伯特可不吃这一套。
He says, does my turmoil amuse you, Jim? And then Jim's like, I'm sorry, I thought you're making a joke. Robert says, what could you possibly have found funny in what I said? What was the joke you thought you heard? Jim is now really backpedaling. He's like, I guess I thought you were approaching it with more of a sarcasm than misery, kind of laughing at your own pain sad clown thing Robert says oh yes How hilarious is it to laugh at clowns the painted gestures of the dying circus industry very funny Jim I get it Oh my gosh
他说：“我的痛苦让你觉得很好笑吗，吉姆？”然后吉姆连忙说：“不好意思，我以为你在开玩笑。”罗伯特说：“你在我刚才的话里到底能发现什么好笑的东西？你以为你听到的笑话是什么？”吉姆现在开始疯狂退缩了。他说：“我猜我以为你是带着几分讽刺而不是痛苦的态度，有点像是在自嘲那种悲伤小丑的风格……”罗伯特说：“哦，是啊。嘲笑小丑多么滑稽啊，去嘲笑走向消亡的马戏业里那些画着彩妆的小丑，真是太好笑了，吉姆，我懂。”哦，天哪！
It's so good. I had to watch the scene twice because this is back to back. Jim getting called out on being a smart ass. Well, next up Meredith is going to offer Aaron a ride to this party. In this scene, she reveals it's really easy for me because you live right by me. And Aaron's like, how do you know that? And Meredith says, because after the Christmas party, Andy followed you home because he's worried that Robert California was gonna stick it in ya. Mm-hmm. So, Aaron's like, oh wow.
太绝了。我把这幕看了两遍，因为这简直是连环暴击——吉姆接连被抓包自作聪明。好吧，接下来梅丽莎提出要载艾琳去这个派对。在这场戏里，她透露说这对她来说太方便了，因为你住的地方离我很近。然后艾琳说：“你怎么知道的？”梅丽莎说：“因为在圣诞派对之后，安迪一路跟踪你回家，因为他担心罗伯特·加利福尼亚会把你给睡了。”嗯哼。所以，艾琳就想：哦，哇。
Aaron's like, he still likes me! Yeah, this is gonna start Aaron on a whole spiral. She is giddy. She thinks Andy has become her weird stalker. She's very excited. The gang are now gonna arrive to Robert's house. They're going to start by feeling the temperature of the pool. Gabe says he thinks the pool is 82, maybe 82 and a half degrees. He's not right, but he's very close. This made me laugh, Angela,
艾琳的反应是：他还是喜欢我！是的，这直接让艾琳陷入了一场情感暴走。她飘飘然了。她觉得安迪已经变成了她的诡异尾随狂。她兴奋极了。大家现在到达了罗伯特的房子。他们从试探泳池的水温开始。盖布说他觉得泳池水温是82度，也许82度半。他猜得不对，但非常接近。这把我逗笑了，安吉拉，
because back during my bread making days, you know, you have to take the temperature of all the ingredients and make sure that you get the exact right temperature balance to make a good sourdough, to make really any good bread dough. You have to take the temperature of the air, the temperature of the flour, and the temperature of the water. There was a time when I could stick my finger in a bowl of water until you what temperature it was, like accurately.
因为回想起我当年做面包的日子，你知道的，你必须测量所有配料的温度，确保获得极其精确的温度平衡才能做出好的酸面包面团，或者做出任何好的面包面团。你必须测量空气温度、面粉温度和水的温度。曾有一段时间，我只要把手指伸进一碗水里就能告诉你它的水温是多少，而且相当准确。
And you know, my bread-baking mentor, Bonnie, that first time it happened, I texted her and I said, I can do this, I can tell the temperature of water by just touching it. That's awesome. Well, Jenna, in this scene, I call busted. What is it? I'm bustin' myself.
而且你知道吗，我的面包烘焙导师邦妮，在我第一次成功时，我发短信告诉她：“我能做到，我只要摸一下就能知道水温。”太棒了。好吧，珍娜，在这场戏里，我必须“自首”。怎么回事？我自己“自首”了。
What are you doin'? My character is in her last trimester Jenna, in this scene, I call busted. What is it? I'm bustin' myself. What are you doin'? My character is in her last trimester of her pregnancy, but gets on her hands and knees, gets on all fours, in a dress to bend over and touch the water? I don't think so. I call busted. I'm trying to think if I did any hands and knees
你干嘛呢？我的角色当时正处于怀孕的最后一个三月期，珍娜，在这场戏里，我必须“自首”。怎么回事？我自己“自首”了。你干嘛呢？我的角色当时正处于怀孕的最后一个三月期，挺着大肚子，却穿着裙子跪在地上、手脚着地去弯腰摸水？才不会呢。我得自首。我在脑子里回想自己超级大肚的时候有没有在瑜伽课上做过任何手脚着地
poses in my yoga class when I was super pregnant. Yeah, in your yoga class. I guess you're right. Are you just like, oh, I'm gonna be at someone's house super pregnant and addressed, but don't worry. I'm gonna drop to the ground so I can fill this pool water. I don't think so. Now Jim is gonna have a talking head where he explains
的姿势。对，在你的瑜伽课上。我想你说得对。你会不会就想：哦，我挺着超级大肚子还穿着裙子去别人家，但没关系。我要趴到地上来测试这个泳池的水温。我才不会呢。现在吉姆有一个独白，他在里面解释说
he's the master of leaving parties early. He's got a whole formula for how he's gonna get out of this party. I totally believe this by the way. I believe if anyone could sneak out of a party early it would be Jim. I mean, I have a friend like this. Listen, he couldn't get out of that dinner party. I don't know why he thinks he's getting out of this pool party. I know.
他是提前离场派对的大师。他有一整套如何从这个派对脱身的秘诀。顺便说一句，我完全相信这一点。我相信如果有人能从派对上悄悄溜走，那绝对是吉姆。我的意思是，我有过这样一个朋友。听着，他可没法从那个晚宴上脱身。我不知道他凭什么觉得自己能从这个泳池派对脱身。我懂。
But we all have someone like that, right? We have a friend who we will look up and we'll be like, where's Neil? And he's like, come on, I leave parties early. I know, you're really good at it. I'm pretty good. Jim's not wrong, by the way.
但我们身边都有这样的人，对吧？我们有个朋友，聊着聊着抬头一看会问：“尼尔去哪儿了？”然后他早就走了。说真的，你确实很擅长提前溜走。我挺擅长的。吉姆说得也没错，顺便说一句。
He has a good strategy. He does. His strategy does not work this time though, because in his like, make a big flashy moment, he takes this picture with Robert and Robert's like, come on, tour the house, come on. Yeah, it's gonna be hard for him to get out of this house tour. Meanwhile, Jessica walks over to Andy and he's fiddling in his pocket. He had been looking at the engagement ring and he has to put in his pocket real quick. Why did he bring it? Why?
他确实有一套好策略。他的确有。不过他的策略这次没用，因为在想要制造一个闪亮高调的瞬间时，他偏偏去和罗伯特合了张影，罗伯特顺势说：“来吧，参观一下房子，走吧。”是的，他这次休想轻易逃掉这个房屋参观。与此同时，杰西卡走向安迪，而安迪正在口袋里摸索着。他刚才一直在看那枚求婚戒指，不得不赶紧把它塞回口袋里。他为什么要把这带上？为什么？
I don't know. Was he gonna propose tonight? At a whole party without replacing the center diamond first. I'm just like, why does he have it? Well, we got a fan question from Jen S in California who said, cringe alert, this is my pick for cringiest episode, but it also has one of my favorite lines that makes me laugh out loud every time it's Andy's line when Jessica asks,
我不知道。难道他今晚就要求婚吗？在一场派对上，甚至都没先把中间的钻石补上。我只想说：他到底为什么要把这东西带着？好吧，我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州的詹·S的粉丝提问，她说：“尴尬警报，这是我心目中最尴尬的一集，但它也有一句我最喜欢的台词，每次听都会让我放声大笑，那就是安迪的台词：当杰西卡问‘你在干嘛呢？’时，他说：‘弹掉我丁丁上的一个小虫子。’”
what are you doing? And he says flicking a bug off my weiner. Please tell me, were there any alts to that line? No, Jen, that was the scripted line and it was always a scripted line. There you have it. It's also how Ed delivered it. He's like flicking a bug off my wiener.
请告诉我，这句台词有什么备选方案吗？没有，詹，这就是剧本里的原话，而且一直都是剧本原话。所以就是这样。这也是艾德演绎它的方式。他演得就像是在说：弹掉我丁丁上的一个小虫子。
Yeah, it's like the you sh, exactly. Erin is gonna have a talking head where she lays out her plan for this party, which is basically in her mind, Andy is not over her, and she's gonna try to make him jealous again. Oh, yes, she's gonna get Dwight. I know. To flirt with her. Wrong person, Erin.
对，就像那个你……完全没错。艾琳有一个独白，她在里面阐述了她对这个派对的计划，基本上在她看来，安迪并没有忘掉她，她要再次试图让他吃醋。哦，是的，她打算找德怀特。我懂。来和她调情。找错人了，艾琳。
Wrong person, nothing casual about Dwight. There was an alternate Erin talking head where she summarizes her relationship with Andy. I'm gonna read it to you. Okay? You date a guy. You find out he was engaged to your coworker so you throw a cake at him. It's over. You start liking him again so you ask him out with a puppet show. He says no. Then he follows you home to make sure that you don't kiss somebody. Then he ignores you at a pool party. Am I right ladies? mean, when you hear it laid out like that, you kind of have to think, maybe this isn't supposed to happen, this relationship.
找错人了，德怀特身上可一点都不“随意”。有一个备选的艾琳独白，她在里面总结了她和安迪的关系。我读给你们听听。好吧。你跟一个家伙约会。你发现他曾和你同事订过婚，于是你朝他脸上砸了个蛋糕。结束了。你开始重新喜欢他，于是你用一场木偶戏向他表白。他拒绝了。然后他一路跟踪你回家，确保你没有去亲吻别人。接着他在泳池派对上无视你。我说的对吗，女士们？我的意思是，当你听到把这些经历一条条列出来时，你不得不去想：也许这段关系从一开始就不该发生。
I'm not for it. I know I wrote to say. I think the signs point to there's someone else. Yeah. Now we're gonna have a scene with some Stanley Sass that I appreciated very much. And so did Christy D from Oregon, who said, I noticed that Stanley moved Andy's pants to sit down by the pool because Andy had thrown his pants on a chair. And Stanley says, pants only need a chair if there's a person in them.
我不看好它。我知道我写过要说的话。我觉得种种迹象都表明——生命中还有别人。好了，接下来有一场充满斯坦利式讽刺（Stanley Sass）的戏，我非常喜欢。来自俄勒冈州的克里斯蒂·D也很喜欢，她说：“我注意到斯坦利把安迪的裤子移开以便在泳池边坐下，因为安迪之前把裤子随手扔在了一把椅子上。而斯坦利说：‘只有当上面坐着人的时候，裤子才需要一把椅子。’”
Stanley, I feel you. You know, one of my pet peeves is when you go to the airport and you're trying to find a seat at your gate and everyone's put all their bags all over the seats. It's like one human being and then like two extra chairs for all their stuff. The stuff goes on the floor, the people go in the chairs. I'm with Stanley. I felt like it was a very mom thing to say. You know? I guess it is.
斯坦利，我太懂你了。你知道的，我的一个宠物恨（极度厌烦的事情）就是当你去机场，试图在登机口找个座位时，每个人都把自己的包占满了周围所有的座位。就像是一个人，然后霸占了另外两个空椅子来放他们的杂物。东西应该放在地上，人应该坐在椅子上。我站斯坦利这边。我觉得这是一句非常“妈妈”风格的话。你知道吗？我想是的。
Well, Andy does find his pants on the floor. There's no ring in the pocket anymore. He's panicking a little bit. Meanwhile, Erin is over trying to enlist Dwight in her plan and he kicks her into the pool. I also love the detail that everyone brought bathing suits but Dwight is gonna swim and some old cut-off jean shorts. Yeah. Well I had to ask Ellie about getting pushed in the pool and
好吧，安迪确实在地板上找到了他的裤子。口袋里的戒指已经不见了。他开始有点慌了。与此同时，艾琳正在那边试图把德怀特拉入她的计划，而德怀特直接一脚把她踢进了泳池。我也很喜欢这个细节：所有人都带了泳衣，但德怀特居然穿着一条剪短的旧牛仔短裤就下水了。是的。好吧，我不得不问问艾琳关于被推下泳池的感受，
also her scenes with Rain and here is what she said. I remember, you know Rain is so weird so you never know if he's joking or not, but he was a very fun person to do that episode with because he's like someone inscrutable and totally, totally just like a big brother. So it was just fun to have any scene with him, but I just remember like sort of coursing around with him in a very sibling kind of way, which makes my heart warm to think about it. Well, I can tell you right now that if you're in a scene with Rain, he fully commits. So if they said Dwight kicks Aaron in the pool, you better get ready because you're going to get kicked across the pool. We're back on the tour and Robert is showing everyone the
以及她和雷恩的对手戏，她是这么说的：“我记得，你知道雷恩这个人真的很古怪，所以你永远不知道他是在开玩笑还是认真的，但他是一个非常有趣、拍这一集时合作起来很开心的人，因为他就像那种高深莫测、完全完全就像个大哥哥一样的人。所以跟他演任何对手戏都很有趣，但我只记得跟他在一起时，那种非常像兄妹般的打闹互动，回想起来让我的心暖洋洋的。”好吧，我现在可以告诉你，如果你跟雷恩演对手戏，他是会百分之百全情投入的。所以如果剧本写着德怀特把艾琳踢进泳池，你最好做好准备，因为你真的会被一脚踢飞进泳池里。我们回到了房屋参观环节，罗伯特正在向大家展示
parlor, aka his sex den, that Susan used as a Pilates studio. Yes, there was a line he said earlier where he said, a beautiful monster stole my forties and then redid my house. It just makes me laugh thinking of how he saw this house and then what she did with it. This room that they're in, it's basically a concrete wall with two big, really tall red base things that looks like there's urns sitting on top of these red pillars
客厅，也就是他的性爱地牢（sex den），苏珊曾把它用作普拉提工作室。是的，他之前说过一句台词：“一个美丽的怪物偷走了我的四十岁，然后把我的房子重新装修了一遍。”一想到他是怎么看待这栋房子以及她后来对它做了什么，我就忍不住想笑。他们所在的这个房间，基本上是一面混凝土墙，旁边有两个非常非常高的红色底座似的东西，看起来就像是放在壁炉两侧红色柱子上的骨灰坛。
on either side of the fireplace. There is a very, very low brown couch with no back support. And one wall that looks like an old metal garage door to me. And then there's the wine collection behind a skinny door. He says there's 1200 bottles. How do you even get in there to get them all? I don't know. I clearly had issues with everything in this room.
这里有一张非常非常低的棕色沙发，没有任何靠背支撑。还有一面墙，对我来说看起来就像一个旧金属车库门。然后是一个藏在窄门后面的红酒收藏区。他说那里有1200瓶藏酒。你到底怎么才能钻进去把它们全拿出来？我不知道。我对这个房间里的每一样东西显然都有意见。
I didn't like anything about it. I vote no in this room. I didn't like anything about it. I vote no on this room, but Oscar is very excited about this wine collection. And the script it said, Toby reaches for a random bottle. Oscar sees it. Oscar says, a 95 Chateau Margot,
我对这里的一切都不满意。我投反对票。我对这个房间投反对票，但奥斯卡对这个红酒收藏区感到兴奋极了。剧本上写着：托比伸手去拿其中一瓶随机的酒。奥斯卡看到了。奥斯卡说：“一瓶95年的查托·马歌（Chateau Margaux）……”
wow, you know your wine. So I had to look up this wine. I did as well. It's real. It's real. And it's expensive. Yeah, depending on which wine you would have chosen that they produced in 1995 it would have cost anywhere from
哇，你很懂酒啊。所以我不得不查一下这款酒。我也是。它是真的。它是真的。而且很贵。是的，根据你选择的他们1995年产的哪种酒，价格从
$900 to $8,000. Yeah, and here's how it's described. It has a medium intensity of deeply pigmented ruby red The nose is cedar-y and high-toned with a chalky mineral touch. On the palette, abundant dark fruit has power in a smooth texture, but the intense core of Cassis fruit needs to open. There are notes of cedar in tobacco tightly woven into the fruit. That's what that means. They got all of that from a superfine. That is pretty amazing to me. I'll tell you who would have appreciated this wine description. Who? Oscar. Yes. Well, he's a member of the
$900 到 $8,000 不等。是的，它是这样被描述的：它具有中等浓度的深色红宝石红色，香气带有雪松和高昂的粉笔矿物气息。口感上，丰富的深色水果在柔顺的质感中充满力量，但黑醋栗果实浓郁的核心需要打开。果香中隐约透出雪松和烟草的气息。这就是那个意思。他们从一瓶极好的酒里品出了所有这些。这对我来说太神奇了。我跟你说谁会欣赏这个品酒词。谁？奥斯卡。是的。嗯，他是
Finer Things Club for a reason, Angela. Well, excuse me, I guess that's how they roll. So would me and my box wine not be admitted? What do you think? I'll tell you something. When you finish box wine, save the bag, fill it with air. You can use it as a pool floaty. Oh wow, this might be why I'm not in the finer things club. By the way, that is what I learned from growing up in the 70s because my mom's friends would have these pool floaties that were odd shapes and they were box wine bags. Wait, that's real. I thought you were making a joke. No. My mom's friend had these little squares in her pool and they were the bags from the box wine.
“精致生活俱乐部”的成员是有原因的，安吉拉。好吧，不好意思，我想他们就是这种风格。所以我和我的盒装酒是不是就不能加入了？你觉得呢？我告诉你一件事。当你喝完盒装酒，把袋子留着，把它充满气。你可以把它当成泳池浮排。哦，哇，这可能就是我为什么进不了精致生活俱乐部的原因。顺便说一句，这是我从70年代长大中学到的，因为我妈妈的朋友们会有这种形状奇特的泳池浮排，它们就是盒装酒的袋子。等等，这是真的。我还以为你在开玩笑。没有。我妈妈的朋友在她的泳池里有这些小正方形，它们就是盒装酒的袋子。
Huh? Like, they're so tiny. They're a little silver squares. We were little. We'd float on them. So the moms would drink the box wine and then fill the bags with air and then toss them to their kids in the pool.
啊？就像，它们太小了。它们是一个个银色的小方块。我们那时还小。我们会漂在它们上面。所以妈妈们喝完盒装酒，然后把袋子充满气，接着把它们扔给泳池里的孩子们。
Yes. All right. OK. Hashtag group in the 70s. And then someone's throwing lawn darts over on the side. Good times. So Steve Burgess says we use the real label for that wine, but we replace the wine with grape juice.
是的。好吧。好吧。70年代的群聊标签。然后有人在旁边扔草坪飞镖。美好的旧时光。所以史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们为那瓶酒用了真的酒标，但我们把酒换成了葡萄汁。
What happened to the wine that had been inside that real bottle I'd like to know? Wow. You know, lady, I once bid on some wine at a silent auction and I got six bottles of wine. It was only like a few hundred dollars and it was a good cause. Well, my dad, who is my dad, as soon as we got home, he started googling each bottle to see if I'd gotten a good deal. Did I get my money's worth? My husband would do the exact same thing and has one of the bottles was worth $1,200. What? Yes. What did you do with it?
我想知道那瓶真酒里面原本的酒去哪了？哇。你知道吗，女士，我曾经在无声拍卖会上竞拍过一些酒，我得到了六瓶酒。只花了幾百美元，而且是为了一个好慈善。好吧，我爸爸，也就是我爸爸，我们一到家，他就开始在谷歌上搜索每一瓶酒，看我是不是捡了个大便宜。我物有所值了吗？我丈夫也会做完全一样的事，其中有一瓶酒价值 1200 美元。什么？是的。你把它怎么处理了？
It's still in my wine fridge. I'm like afraid to drink it because I'm like, what is the occasion that calls for a $1,200 bottle? It's probably going to go bad, but I was overwhelmed. I will don't let it go bad. I know. We put a special piece00 bottle of wine. It's probably gonna go bad, but I was overwhelmed. I will don't let it go bad. I know, we put a special piece of tape on it, so we know which one it is. Do you know when, like, does it have an expiration date? Like, what's the rule?
它还在我的酒柜里。我有点不敢喝，因为我在想，什么场合才配得上一瓶 1200 美元的酒？它可能要变质了，但我当时不知所措。我一定会不让它变质的。我知道。我们在上面贴了一块特殊的胶带，这样我们就知道是哪一瓶了。你知道什么时候，比如，它有保质期吗？比如，规则是什么？
I mean, wine turns eventually, right? Yeah. But I don't know. This made me think of it. When I was looking up the, how much the Chateau Margot costs. I have it, I have it. What?
我是说，酒最终会变质的，对吧？对。但我不知道。这让我想起了这件事。当我查阅玛歌酒庄要多少钱时。我有，我有。什么？
When you can put your hair in a high ponytail with your broken shoulders. Yes! You get to open that bottle of wine. Okay. I think we're just a few months away. Okay. So get ready. You better call me.
当你能用你受伤的肩膀把头发扎成一个高马尾时。太棒了！你就可以打开那瓶酒了。好吧。我想我们再过几个月就可以了。好吧。所以准备好。你最好给我打电话。
I'm coming over. Okay, I will. We also had a fan question from the scene from Justin P and Fresno, California, who said, was the bottle of wine that John had in this episode smaller than the others or does he just have really big hands? Justin, I went after a richer question. I looked at it and I was like, oh my gosh, it is like an optical illusion, like maybe John just has giant hands, but no, his bottle of wine is smaller. It was actually scripted that Jim purposely grabs a half bottle of wine because he is reluctantly
我要过去。好的，我会的。我们还有一个来自加利福尼亚州弗雷斯诺的贾斯汀·P的粉丝问题，他说，约翰在这集里拿的那瓶酒比其他的要小，还是他只是手真的很大？贾斯汀，我追问了一个更深刻的问题。我看着它，心想，哦天哪，这就像是一个视错觉，也许约翰的手就是巨大无比，但并没有，他的酒瓶确实更小。剧本里其实写的就是吉姆故意抓了半瓶酒，因为他很不情愿
on this tour. So his bottle is smaller. That is a really good cut. I know, it made me laugh. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, Dwight is going to sign on to be Aaron's accomplice in trying to get Andy's attention. You know what's the best way to flirt with someone? I mean, I think I know the way it's not the best way, but go on. Maybe just poke them in the face over and over.
参加这次参观。所以他的酒瓶比较小。这真的是一个非常好的剪辑。我知道，这把我逗笑了。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，德怀特将同意成为艾琳的同谋，试图引起安迪的注意。你知道调情最好的方式是什么吗？我是说，我觉得我知道那种方式不是最好的，但你继续说。也许就是一遍又一遍地戳他们的脸。
Like flick their nose, poke them in the face. That's how you flirt. Oh my gosh. How awkward are Dwight and Erin at flirting? Oh my gosh. Also in this scene, I have a juicy sweatpants sighting. Oh, I saw them. They were all the rage Kelly's wearing purple juicy sweatpants.
就像弹他们的鼻子，戳他们的脸。那就是你们调情的方式。哦天哪。德怀特和艾琳调情有多尴尬？哦天哪。同样在这个场景中，我看到了多汁运动裤（Juicy sweatpants）的出场。哦，我看到了。它们当时风靡一时，凯莉穿着紫色的多汁运动裤。
Yes, she finds the engagement ring on the ground. What is this? Oh boy. I'm sorry. If you find a piece of jewelry on the ground at someone's home, do you not take it to the host? Do you not say, hey, did someone drop an engagement ring? Guys, no.
是的，她在地上找到了订婚戒指。这是什么？哦，天哪。我很抱歉。如果你在某个人的家里地上发现了一件首饰，你难道不会把它交还给主人吗？你难道不会说，嘿，有人掉了一枚订婚戒指吗？伙计们，才不。
No. No, I just keep her as far as Kelly's concerned. You put him in that juicy sweatpants pocket. I guess so. We're in Robert's fancy kitchen where he's talking about, you know, his fantasy of eating a leg of mutton, et cetera, et cetera. But this is where Oscar decides to invite Toby to join his wine club. Yes, because Toby is pretending like he knows good wine.
不。不，就凯莉而言，我直接把它留着。你把它放进那条多汁运动裤的口袋里。我猜是的。我们在罗伯特的豪华厨房里，他在谈论，你知道的，他关于吃羊腿的幻想，等等，等等。但就在这里，奥斯卡决定邀请托比加入他的品酒俱乐部。是的，因为托比在假装自己很懂酒。
Mm-hmm. There's a Toby talking head where he says, I'm playing a dangerous game. And then he chucks his wine. I don't understand how Paul is shaking. I was like, what is happening? What is happening? I don't even know how to describe it. He like does this thing. and I don't know, and can see me. But he goes like, it's like, don't wear it. He like, wrap it, wrap it, wrap it, I don't even know. It made me laugh out loud.
嗯哼。有一个托比的单人访谈，他说，我在玩一个危险的游戏。然后他把酒一饮而尽。我不明白保罗是怎么抖动身体的。我当时想，发生什么了？发生什么了？我甚至不知道该怎么形容它。他就像是做了这个动作。我不知道，而且你看得见我。但他动作就像是，就像是，别穿它。他就像是，把它裹起来，裹起来，裹起来，我甚至都不知道。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。
I don't think it was intentional. Maybe that's how ball of drinks from a bottle, I don't know. Well, I think it was very late when we filmed this talking head because we did get a question from someone who pointed out that this talking head, it looks a little different from other talking heads. And Steve Burgess said, yeah, we were rushing in post. They had to kind of like make up for the fact that like it was pitch dark.
我觉得这不是刻意的。也许保罗从瓶子里喝酒就是那个样子的，我不知道。嗯，我觉得我们拍摄这个单人访谈时已经很晚了，因为我们确实收到了一个人的提问，他指出这个单人访谈看起来和其他的单人访谈有点不同。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，是的，我们在后期制作时时间很赶。他们不得不某种程度上弥补外面漆黑一片的事实。
Yeah. Yes. There was no light coming in like we caught this as quickly as we could. Okay. I don't know. Maybe everyone was just a little loopy at this point. Yeah. Maybe they were like, Paul, remember at the end, you have to check it.
是的。是的。没有光线照进来，我们尽可能快地抓拍了这一幕。好吧。我不知道。也许大家在这个时候都有点晕乎乎的。是的。也许他们当时在想，保罗，记住最后你得把它干了。
So we just quickly like, yeah, I guess so. Well, Meredith is very impressed by Robert Swimmingpool. She said it's a choice pool. No top scum, no band-aids. That's an A plus pool for Meredith. I mean, there's nothing grosser than being in a swimming pool and then, you know, doing a lap and then all of a sudden you come up and there's a band-aid that's floated by you.
所以我们只是很快地，是的，我猜是这样。好吧，梅雷迪思对罗伯特的游泳池印象深刻。她说这是一个优质的游泳池。没有漂浮的浮沫，没有创可贴。对梅雷迪思来说，这是一个A+级的游泳池。我的意思是，没有什么比在游泳池里游泳，然后，你知道的，游了一圈，突然浮上来一个创可贴从你身边漂过更恶心的了。
It's true. Angela, we got a fan question from Jake M in North Carolina and I really didn't know where to place this in the episode, but I thought it was worth discussing. Jake said, can we talk about how when Robert California came to interview to be the regional manager at Dundermifland, He was already living in this house. So how in the world did he have this house?
确实如此。安吉拉，我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的杰克·M的一个粉丝问题，我真的不知道该把这个问题放在这一集的什么地方，但我觉得它值得讨论。杰克说，我们能谈谈当罗伯特·加利福尼亚来邓德米夫林面试区域经理时，他当时就已经住在这个房子里了吗？所以他到底是怎么拥有这栋房子的？
And why did he think that a manager job at a printer paper company was a good fit for him? What is your theory? I have my theory. I have no theory. I actually haven't thought about it until Jake mentioned it. Well, Jake, here's my idea. Tell me what you think. I sort of see Robert as this very wealthy eccentric guy. and thought about it, so Jake mentioned it. Well, Jake, here's my idea. Tell me what you think. I sort of see Robert as this very wealthy eccentric guy. I don't know where his money comes from,
为什么他会觉得打印纸公司的经理职位对他很合适？你的理论是什么？我有我的理论。我没有什么理论。事实上，在杰克提到之前我根本没想过这个问题。好吧，杰克，这就是我的想法。告诉我你的想法。我有点把罗伯特看作是一个非常富有且古怪的家伙。想到过，所以杰克提到了它。好吧，杰克，这是我的想法。告诉我你觉得怎么样。我有点把罗伯特看作是一个非常富有且古怪的家伙。我不知道他的钱是从哪来的，
maybe it's generational money. And he's just bored, and he just decides to do things. He's a little bit of a con man. I mean, he's never sold paper before, but I think he just likes to dabble in in things and this is what he decided to do that month. Right, almost like the job is more of a hobby. Exactly. Something to fill his time. Something to fill his time. A way to people watch, a way to play games with people. Remember how on Halloween he did that crazy long monologue about being afraid. I like your theory. Thank you. I just think he's a bored rich guy.
也许是家族世代传下来的钱。他只是觉得无聊，然后就决定做点事情。他有点像个骗子。我是说，他以前从来没卖过纸，但我认为他只是喜欢涉猎各种事情，这就是他那个月决定要做的事。没错，简直就像这份工作更像是一种爱好。完全正确。用来打发时间的事情。用来打发时间的事情。一种观察人们的方式，一种和人们玩游戏的方式。还记得万圣节那天他那段关于恐惧的疯狂的长篇大论吗？我喜欢你的理论。谢谢。我只是觉得他是一个无聊的有钱人。
Val was gonna ask Darryl to go on the water with her. Yeah, but Darryl is hesitating. Mm-hmm. He's like nervous about taking off his shirt in front of Val. Basically, he feels a little insecure. Yeah. We have a fan catch from Zoe B in Charlotte, North Carolina
瓦尔打算让达里尔和她一起去水里。是的，但达里尔在犹豫。嗯哼。他在瓦尔面前脱掉衬衫感到有点紧张。基本上，他觉得有点不够自信。是的。我们有一个来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的佐伊·B的粉丝抓包
who says at 12 minutes, Meredith is wet and telling Darryl and Val they need to get in the pool, but in the very next scene at 12 minutes and 10 seconds in the background of Darryl's talking head, Meredith is completely dry and just dipping her toes in. Zoe, I caught that too. She's not just wet. She is drenched, head to toe, her hair is wet. She's clearly been in the water a while.
她说在12分钟时，梅雷迪思全身湿透，告诉达里尔和瓦尔他们需要下水，但在紧接着12分钟10秒的下一个场景中，在达里尔单人访谈的背景里，梅雷迪思完全是干的，只是把脚趾浸在水里。佐伊，我也发现了。她不仅仅是湿了。她是从头到脚湿透了，头发也是湿的。她显然已经在水里待了一会儿了。
And then in the next shot, she's totally dry and just putting her feet in. I thought that was a great catch. Also in the background of Gerald's talking head, you can see Val. She's doing laps. A few other people are also swimming. Yes. And it was so funny because when we were doing our interview with Amina for Christmas wishes, she brought this episode up. She had a lot to say
然后在下一个镜头中，她完全干了，只是把脚放进水里。我觉得这是一个很棒的抓包。同样在达里尔单人访谈的背景里，你可以看到瓦尔。她在游来游去。还有其他几个人也在游泳。是的。这太有趣了，因为当我们采访阿米娜谈论圣诞愿望时，她提到了这一集。她有很多话要说
about filming pool party and we said we have to save this and play it when we break down pool party. Oh yeah, Amina and I really commiserated about being in that pool. So here it is. So I don't know if this made it to the blooper, but I do like to tell it because I found it to be funny and life threatening, which was when we went and we were shooting at Robert California's house. We were at the pool. And so I'm a decent swimmer. They were like, we're going to put you in the pool and I was like, that let's go pool time. And so I had very long hair at that time.
关于拍摄泳池派对，我们说我们得把这段留着，等我们剖析泳池派对时播出来。哦，是的，阿米娜和我真的对在这个游泳池里拍戏感到同病相怜。所以它来了。所以，我不知道这有没有被剪进NG花絮里，但我真的很想讲出来，因为我发现它既搞笑又危及生命，那就是当我们去罗伯特·加利福尼亚的房子拍摄时。我们在泳池边。而且我游泳还算可以。他们说，我们要把你放进泳池里，我就想，好啊，泳池时间到。所以那时我的头发非常长。
I had dreadlocks. And so I put my locks up on top of my head because I'm sensible. And that's what you do when you're going to go swimming in dreadlocks. You do not swim with them down, not with the amount that I had. So I put them up on top of my head and they were like, Oh, no, no, no, no, you're going to look much better if you take them down and like pardon me. And they take them down, you know, and I was like, Oh, God. And of course you do it because you know what they're going for.
我梳着脏辫。所以我把脏辫盘在头顶，因为我很理智。当你梳着脏辫去游泳时，你就会这么做。你绝对不能披散着头发游泳，尤其是像我这么多的头发。所以我把它们盘在头顶，结果他们说，哦，不，不，不，不，如果你把头发散开，你会看起来性感得多，然后，打扰一下。他们把头发散开了，你知道的，我当时想，哦，天哪。当然你会照做，因为你知道他们的目的。
They thought it would look sexier, but remember they covered that room. They heated the pool. They heated the room. Remember it was warm in there So there was so muggy and yes, but they had me in that pool y'all and that water got in my hair And it was like an albatross. Oh, no, and they had me doing laps. Yeah, I was like look here I'm athletic don't get me wrong, but Jesus What are you all trying to do me in here? And I literally like by by the end?
他们觉得这样看起来更性感，但记住他们把那个房间封起来了。他们把泳池加热了。他们把房间加热了。记住里面很暖和。所以里面非常闷热，是的，但他们把我弄进那个泳池里，天哪，水进了我的头发里，它就像一只信天翁。哦，不，他们还让我来回游。是的，我当时想，听着，我很擅长运动，别误会我，但是天哪，你们到底想把我怎么样？我真的就像是到了最后？
I felt like it was literally just my head was above I was doing like that just that's survival swim where you'd literally just your mouth and your nose are out of the water And I'm like, yeah, that's what happened in life. Oh my gosh Yes, in the background you're doing laps. Yes. Yes Yes doing laps and almost dying. Like, yes, that is what is happening in the background. This valve is literally about to drown because of her locks. I wish I would have known that because I would have come over.
我觉得简直只有我的脑袋露在外面，我在做那种，就是那种求生游泳，你的嘴和鼻子刚好露出水面，我就想，是的，生活里就是这样。哦，天哪，是的，在背景里你正在来回游。是的。是的，来回游而且差点淹死。就像是，是的，背景里发生的就是这个。这个瓦尔简直因为她的脏辫快要溺水了。我真希望我当时知道这件事，因为我会走过去的。
They had me doing laps and my character was fake pregnant. And they bought me a pregnancy bathing suit and they put a big pregnancy pillow. I remember. But guess what happens? pregnancy bathing suit and they put a big pregnancy pillow. But guess what happens? They wanted me doing laps and that pillow absorbed all the water. So now I'm trying to do laps and I'm getting heavier and heavier. And I'm starting to sink. I was like, guys, when we were like rehearsing, I said, I'm going to need a kickboard. I am sinking.
他们让我来回游，而我的角色是假装怀孕。他们给我买了一件孕妇泳衣，还放了一个巨大的孕妇枕。我记得。但你猜怎么着？孕妇泳衣，他们还放了一个巨大的孕妇枕。但你猜怎么着？他们想让我来回游，而那个枕头吸收了所有的水。所以现在我在努力来回游，而且我变得越来越重。我开始往下沉。我当时想，伙计们，当我们排练时，我说，我需要一块浮板。我在下沉。
Get it. So you know exactly what I'm talking about. I would have shared my kickboard with you. They were just slowly killing all the actresses on the office and that pool party. That's what was happening. You were literally on the death walk. The rounding. Like I had no idea you went through the same thing, but I remember that pregnancy pillow. Now I remember that. I couldn't get out of the pool. It weighed so much. I had my own trauma. I didn't have bandwidth for your trauma.
拿来。所以你完全知道我在说什么。我会把我的浮板分给你的。他们只是在办公室的那个泳池派对上慢慢地杀死所有的女演员。这就是当时发生的事情。你简直是在走死亡行军。沉下去。就像我不知道你也经历了同样的事情，但我记得那个孕妇枕。现在我想起来了。我根本游不出泳池。它太重了。当我站起来时，我看起来就像尿了自己几个小时一样。
I really was so. I had no idea you were going through that. I was so trying not to drown. And you know what, when I went to get out of the pool, it was so heavy. Yeah. And then when I stood up, I just looked like I was peeing myself for hours.
是不是水就从枕头里流出来？是的，百分之百，而且我的头发湿了一整天，我还以为我想要脏辫效果呢。对我来说那是漫长的一天半。那是漫长的一天半。但我们在那个地方有壮丽的视野。就像是一个阳台或者某种我们走到外面的情况。我们能把椅子搬到外面去
Is it would just drain out of the pillow? Yeah, no 100% and my hair was wet all day, which I just thought I wanted for lots. It was a day and a half for me. That was a day and a half. But we had that spectacular view out on that. It was like a veranda or some situation where we were out. We were able to put our chairs out there
然后俯瞰山谷。外面的情况非常壮观。但是，拍摄，我当时想，好的，我们上吧。哦，天哪。我完全不知道。是的。一提到里面有多热，阿米娜就有一种发自内心的记忆。那年这个时候外面很冷。
and just kind of look out at the valley. It was a spectacular situation out there. But yeah, shooting was, I was like, all right, let's go. Oh my God. I had no idea. Yeah. The minute Amina brought up how hot it was in there was such a visceral memory. It was cold out this time of year.
为了确保我们所有人都保暖，他们通常会用那些送空调的管道，但他们送来了暖气。好吧。然后我们在泳池里，接着有所有的灯光，而且全都被闷在里面，越来越闷热。但如果你没有戏份，你就会出去，而且去我们的拖车太远了。
So to make sure we all stayed warm, they had like the normally like the tubes that would bring ACN, but they brought in heat. Okay. And then we were in a pool, and then there were all the lights, and it was all trapped, and it was getting mugger and mugger. But then you would go out if you didn't have a scene, and it was too far to go to our trailers.
所以他们把几间卧室改造成了你可以闲逛的区域。我有一张照片，因为我们在没戏的时候会觉得非常冷。所以他们会给我们长袍或者那些保暖夹克。我们身上湿漉漉的。太恶心了。我一有机会就想脱掉那件泳衣，因为就像我说的，我的泳衣里面有一个海绵质地的全尺寸大枕头。
So they had a few bedrooms they kind of made into areas where you could hang out. I have a picture because we would get really cold when we weren't in scenes. So they would have robes or those warming jackets for us. And we kind of be wet. It was so gross. I would want to get out of that bathing suit as soon as I could because like I said, there was a full spongy pillow inside my bathing suit.
它完全吸收了所有的水。所以即使我开始变干，水还是会顺着我的腿流下来。太恶心了。所以我有一张我们所有人靠在一起闲逛的照片，大家都在看手机。我有那张照片，然后在我们拍摄的另一天，他们说我们可以去
That was completely absorbing all the water. So even if I started to dry, I would have water running down my legs. It was disgusting. And so I have this picture of us all just kind of lounging and everyone's on their phones. I have that picture and then on another day that we filmed, they said that we could go and hang out
网球场的泳池房闲逛。哦，对，那里有一张乒乓球桌，但我们不应该碰里面的其他东西。所以有这样一个房间，它俯瞰着网球场，里面有一张乒乓球桌，我和布ライ恩、奥斯卡以及扎克·伍兹一起去打了乒乓球，真的超级好玩，而且正如阿米娜所说，我拥有绝佳的视野，人们听说网球场房间的事后
in the tennis court pool house. Oh, yeah, that I had a ping pong table, but we shouldn't touch anything else in there. So there was this room, it overlooked the tennis court, but I had a ping pong table, and so me and Brian and Oscar and Zach Woods all went and played ping pong pong and it was so much fun and I had this gorgeous view like the mean is talking about people heard about the tennis court room
就纷纷过来串门闲逛。我必须说，我对这一集了解得越多，听了你、阿米娜和埃莉的经历之后，嗯，我想也许我很高兴我拍了这一集。我本来想说，是的，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很高兴，很glad（原文如此）。台词，她说，这行不通。我认为性感吃东西是个死胡同。我只想说这个。我想让你们所有人都听我把话说完。我认为性感吃东西总是死胡同。我不知道。
and they started to come down and hang out. I have to say the more I've learned about this episode and after I heard your experience and a mean as experience Ellie's experience um, I think maybe I'm glad I made this one. I was gonna say yeah, glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad I'm line where she says, it's not working. I think sexy eating is a dead end. I just want to say this. I want you all to hear me out. I think sexy eating is always a dead end. I don't know.
不，我不想看你性感地吃东西。我不知道。我觉得，你在哪里觉得吃东西是性感的？我告诉你什么时候。什么时候。蒂莫西·柴勒梅德。桃子。《请以你的名字呼唤我》。我没看过。好吧，你会收回你刚才说的话。我不知道。我不知道我会不会。当他吃
No, I don't want to see you sexy eating. I don't know. I think where, where have you thought eating is sexy? I'll tell you when. When. Timothy Shalamay. Peach. Call me by your name. I haven't seen it. Well, you'll take back everything you just said. I don't know. I don't know if I will. When he eats
那个桃子的时候，女士。哦，天哪。哦，老天爷。萨姆，我能在这个问题上得到一点支持吗？是的，你是对的。谢谢你，萨姆。是的。好吧，我得去找来看看。他吃桃子为什么是这样？它是电影的一部分吗？这是试图诱惑像……这是一个完整的桥段。好吧，我会看的，然后我会发表意见，我会让你知道的。我现在有点害怕了，好吧。我的意思是，我想我只是个老古板。就像曾经有那样一个广告，人们吃芝士汉堡就像……哦，是的。是的。一点也不性感。我不想看你那样吃汉堡。是的，那个女演员是谁，或者是个模特，她吃那个汉堡吃得超级性感？一点也不性感。一点也不性感。显然，显然我才是性感吃东西的目标受众。
that peach lady. Oh my god. Oh good lord. Sam, can I get like a second on this one? Yes, you are correct. Thank you Sam. Yes. Okay, I'll have to find it. Why is you eating a peach? Does it part of the movie? It's the trying to lure like a... It's a whole thing. All right, I will watch it and then I will get on our toes and I'll let you know. I'm scared now, okay. I mean, I guess I'm just an old prude. Like, there was that commercial where people would eat like a cheeseburger and like a... Oh, yeah. Yeah. Not sexy. I don't want to see you eat a burger like that. Yeah, who is the actress who does that or a model and she really sexily eats that burger? It's not sexy. It's not sexy. Clearly, clearly I'm the demographic for sexy eating.
你喜欢性感吃东西。好吧。我是说，我只是吃你的汉堡。我是说去观看。我开车去了得来速点那个汉堡。哦，天哪。我再也不想拍了。现在他们决定他们能做的最浪漫的调情方式就是在游泳池里进行水上鸡斗。是的。于是他们开始在安吉拉的游泳道里玩水上鸡斗。嘿。是的。你可能一直在问自己，为什么安吉拉·马丁要参加罗伯特·加利福尼亚的泳池派对？我猜是为了锻炼身体？好吧，安吉拉，你提到这个可真有意思。
You like sexy eating. Okay. I mean, I just eat your burger. I mean to watch. I went through the drive-through and ordered that burger. Oh my god. I never want to work on me. Now they've decided the most romantic type of flirting they can do is having a chicken fight in the swimming pool. Yes. So they start their chicken fighting right in Angela's swimming lane. Hello. Yeah. You might have asked yourself why is Angela Martin going to Robert California's pool party? I guess to get some exercise in? Well, Angela, it's funny you should mention.
史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，每天收工后，我们的导演查尔斯·麦克杜格尔都会在那个泳池里游几圈来锻炼身体。哦，天哪。所以，我不知道。好吧，我得亮出一张胡扯牌。是什么？你告诉我。
Steve Burgess told me that every day after rap, our director Charles McDougall swam laps and that pool for exercise. Oh my gosh. So I don't know. Well, I need to play a bullsh**t card. What is it? You tell me.
如果你看到安吉拉·马丁怀孕的肚子，你就告诉我。我在显眼的地方游泳，就在德怀特和艾琳旁边。你看到安吉拉·马丁的肚子了吗？嗯，没有，我是说，因为它在水面以下，对吧？完全正确。哦，天哪。完全正确。哦，天哪。在……哦，天哪。
You tell me if you see Angela Martin's pregnant belly. I swim in plain view, right by Dwight and Aaron. Do you see Angela Martin's belly? Well, no, I mean, because it's underwater, right? Exactly. Oh boy. Exactly. Oh boy. After. Oh boy.
在游了一会儿开始往下沉，因为这个他们没考虑到的巨型海绵会吸收所有的水之后，我走到我们的编剧欧文面前。我说，欧文，你绝对看不到我的肚子。绝对看不到。我能把这东西从我的泳衣里拿出来吗？嗯哼。
After swimming for a bit and starting to sink because this giant sponge they didn't think about would actually absorb all the water, I went up to our writer Owen. I said, Owen, there's no way you're seeing my belly. There's no way. Can I please take this thing out of my bathing suit? Mm-hmm.
而他的反应是，我觉得你还是留着它吧。我们可能会看到。可能会发生点什么。我当时就想，呃-huh，呃-huh。好吧。我转向了马特·松，他为我们拍摄了所有水下摄像机的镜头。我对他说，马特，你能看到这个孕肚吗？他的反应是，可能看不到。所以你猜我做了什么？什么？你把它脱掉了。我把它猛地拽了出来。你才没有。我把它猛地拽出来，然后随手甩到泳池边，把它塞在了一把椅子后面。哦，天哪！
And he was like, I feel like you should have it. We might see it. Something could happen. I was like, uh-huh, uh-huh. Okay. I turned to Matt's own who was shooting all the underwater camera stuff for us. And I said, Matt, are you gonna see this pregnant belly? He was like, probably not. So guess what I did? What? You took it off. I yanked it out. You did not. I yanked it out and I slopped it over the side of the pool and I tucked it behind a chair. Oh my God!
我就在隔板后面！布赖恩和我把头探过去。你说得对。我当时想，去他的假肚子。哦，天哪。直到今天我才把这事告诉任何人。菲利斯知道了。她算是看到我把它塞到椅子后面了。接下来，罗伯特要向所有人展示，这是他的卧室吗，里面有双熊皮地毯
I am behind the partition! Brian and I are picking our heads over. You're right. I was like, f*** the fake belly. Oh boy. I never told anyone that till today. Phyllis knew. She kind of saw me shove it behind the chair. Next up, Robert is going to show everyone, is it his bedroom with his double-bear skin rug
然后他们才转到放映室，那是为了观看情色电影而建造的？背景抓包。有没有其他人注意到奥斯卡在狂饮他的葡萄酒时？底部有一块写着“奥斯卡”的蓝色胶带。安吉拉，有人注意到吗？来自加利福尼亚州亨廷顿海滩的玛丽亚·C和来自伦敦的伊莎贝尔·C呢？还有许多其他人。
before they move on to the screening room, which was built for watching erotic cinema? Background catch. Did anyone else catch when Oscar is chugging his wine? There's a piece of blue tape that says Oscar on the bottom. Did anyone catch it, Angela? How about Mariah C. from Huntington Beach, California, and Isabelle C. from London? And many others.
这是连拍胶带。只要我们要喝的任何饮料或任何盘子食物上都会贴这个。你会得到一小块写着你名字的胶带，这样他们就知道该把东西还给谁。好吧，他们忘了把它撕下来。你知道至少奥斯卡的真名在剧里就叫奥斯卡，因为你当时可能在摇晃，上面可能写着约翰。是的。我为这个场景抓到一个亮点：这个物品在这个剧集里一直都在，但直到现在它才真正击中了我，那就是盖比的毛衣看起来像是来自《我的世界》（Minecraft）。是的，是一堆方块，而且是绿色的。是的，我
This is the continuity tape. They would put this on any drink that we ever had to drink or any plate of food You'd get a little piece of tape with your name on it so they knew who to give it back to. Well They forgot to take it off. You know at least Oscar's name is Oscar on the show Because you could have just been swinging and it might have said John. Yes. I have a catch for this scene This item has been in the episode the entire time, but it wasn't until now that it really hit me Which is that Gabe sweater looks like it's from Minecraft. Yes, it's a bunch of cubes and it's green. Yeah I
想你能看出来我们有孩子。是的。我们都做过《我的世界》主题的生日蛋糕。是的，我给我儿子做了一个《我的世界》生日蛋糕。乔希有一年给凯德做过。你能把它们发到播客里吗？因为我真的很自豪。哦，是的，我会的。它们两个做出来都太可爱了。好吧，安迪打算通过让凯莉相信戴着可能属于一段失败婚姻的戒指会带来厄运，从而试图把戒指从她手里拿回来。你不知道这枚戒指经历了什么历史。
Guess you can tell we have kids. Yeah We both have done birthday cakes that were a Minecraft theme. Yes, I made my son a Minecraft birthday cake. Josh made Cade one one year. Will you put them in pod because I'm real proud of it? Oh yeah, I will. They both turned out so cute. Well, Andy is going to attempt to get the ring back from Kelly by convincing her it's bad luck to where the ring of possibly a failed marriage. You don't know the history this ring has had.
菲利斯表示赞同。伙计们，我在网上查了这个，这是一种常见的迷信。哦，真的吗？嗯哼。根据我读过的一篇文章，它说，你永远不应该试戴别人的结婚戒指。人们认为结婚戒指带有着精神上的纽带。通过佩戴别人的结婚戒指，尤其是破碎婚姻的戒指，你可能会预先注定你的婚姻命运。例如，如果结婚戒指，尤其是破碎婚姻的戒指，你可能会预先注定你的婚姻命运。例如，如果结婚戒指属于一对不幸福的夫妻，那么潜在地你的
Phyllis agrees. You guys, I looked this up online and this is a common superstition. Oh, really? Mm-hmm. According to one article I read, it said, you should never try on someone else's wedding ring. Wedding rings are believed to carry spiritual ties. By wearing someone else's wedding ring, especially one of a broken marriage, you could potentially predestine your wedding fate. For instance, if the wedding ring, especially one of a broken marriage, you could potentially pre-destin your wedding fate. For instance, if the wedding ring belongs to an unhappy couple, then potentially your
婚姻也可能会变得悲惨。好吧，我想给你们看看我现在戴的东西。我知道。当我分享这个的时候，我就知道你会觉得，嗯，你可能想踩一下刹车，因为我戴着我祖母的结婚戒指。那是她去世时传给我的。它很漂亮。我特意戴着它，因为我的外祖母和外祖父是真爱。
marriage could also become miserable. Well, I want to show you what I'm wearing right now. I know. I knew when I shared this that you were going to be like, um, you might want to pump the brakes because I am wearing my grandmother's wedding ring. That was passed on to me when she died. It's beautiful. And I wear it specifically because my grandma and my grandpa were true love.
关于他们，我知道的一件事，当你在他们身边时就会非常清楚，那就是他们对彼此是如此绝对地忠诚，他们在生活中经历的一切，你唯一可以依靠的就是他们对彼此的爱。我对自己的婚姻也有这种感觉。我觉得李就是我的真爱。所以我喜欢我的手上拥有双倍的真爱。我喜欢这样。凯莉和菲利斯决定这枚戒指必须被销毁。是的，他们把它放在一个小船里。他们把它点燃了。纸船。那是要去哪里？
One of the things that I know about them that was so clear when you were around them was that they were so utterly committed to one another and everything they went through in their lives, the one thing you could count on was their love for one another. And I feel that way about my own marriage. I feel like Lee is my true love. And so I like to have double true love on my hands. I love that. Kelly and Phyllis are going to decide the ring needs to be destroyed. Yeah, they put it in a little boat. They like set it on fire. A paper boat. Where is that going?
很明显，是游进泳池里。或者可能是泳池的过滤系统，然后泳池就会坏掉。我不知道。这太奇怪了。太奇怪了。他们表现得好像在池塘或河流边一样。我知道。他们在一个室内游泳池里。
Obviously, into the pool. Or maybe the pool's filtration system and then the pool's gonna break. I don't know. It's very odd. It's very odd. They're acting like they're at like a pond or a river. I know. They're in an indoor swimming pool.
我知道。杰丝和安迪现在决定加入水上鸡斗。然后他们开始大杀四方。是的，他们表现得非常好。这也是我喜欢杰西卡的原因之一。她很乐意奉陪。她就像是，我来陪你玩你那怪异的泳池游戏，在你那个令人毛骨悚然的老板家里办的非常奇特的派对。
I know. Jess and Andy now decide to join the chicken fight. And they proceed to kick ass. Yeah, they're doing very well. This is another reason I like Jessica. She's up for it. She's like, I'll do your weird pool game, your very odd party at the home of your creepy boss.
是的，我支持你。我们上吧。嗯，有一个被删掉的关于杰西卡水上鸡斗技能的单人访谈。这里是。杰西卡说，我和我哥哥从小就是我们游泳俱乐部的鸡斗冠军。我是说，我们击败了施特劳斯双胞胎。
Yeah, I'm here for you. Let's go. Well, there was a deleted Jessica talking head about her chicken fighting skills. Here it is. Jessica says, my brother and I were the chicken fight champions of our swim club growing up. I mean, we beat the Strauss twins.
哦，好吧，我猜有人不是在康涅狄格州西哈特福德长大的。哦，那太搞笑了。他们击败了施特劳斯双胞胎。好吧，我们收到了来自得克萨斯州的萨拉·W的粉丝问题，她说在水上鸡斗的场景中，请追踪杰西卡腿上消失又重现的瘀伤。
Oh, okay, I guess somebody didn't grow up in West Hartford, Connecticut. Oh, that was funny. They beat the Strauss twins. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah W. and Texas who said during the chicken fight scene, please track the case of the disappearing, reappearing bruise on Jessica's leg.
哦，不。我完全也注意到了这一点。哦，天哪。是的，在不同的镜头中，你要么能看到瘀伤，要么能看到很明显是为了遮盖瘀伤而涂上的一些淡妆。所以我的理论是，在这一幕的第一条拍摄中，他们注意到有瘀伤，于是叫来化妆师，让他们在上面涂了一些防水
Oh, no. I totally noticed this, too. Oh, my gosh. Yes, in the different shots, you either see a bruise or you see what is very clearly some light makeup that was placed over the bruise to hide it. So my theory is that in the first take of this, they noticed there's a bruise and they called in makeup, they had them put some waterproof
化妆品，但后来他们最终还是使用了第一条拍摄的一些镜头。好吧，水上鸡斗要结束了，因为艾琳一心想要赢过杰西卡。她紧紧勒住并窒息了德怀特。他昏过去了。是的，他沉入水底了。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州的布兰登·R的粉丝问题，他说，在水里、周围以及水下拍摄有什么额外的复杂情况吗？我猜德怀特假装溺水的戏份一定有安全会议。
makeup on it, but then they still ended up using some of the first take. Well, the chicken fighting is going to come to an end because Aaron is so determined to beat Jessica. She clenches down and suffocates Dwight. He passes out. Yes, he goes under the water. We had a fan question from Brandon R. and Illinois who said, where there are any added complications for filming in and around and underwater. I imagine there had to be a safety meeting for Dwight's fake drowning.
嗯，布兰登，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们为所有这些水上鸡斗镜头配备了特技协调员。我们每天还有值班救生员。我们为拍摄德怀特在水下的戏份使用了一个水下支架。史蒂夫说，我们其实原本打算拍摄更多水下内容的，但我们时间不够了。是的。但是，是的。
Well Brandon's Steve Burgess said we had a stunt coordinator for all of those chicken fight scenes. We also had a lifeguard on duty every day. We used an underwater rig for shooting Dwight under the water. And Steve said we'd actually intended to shoot more underwater stuff, but we ran out of time. Yeah. But yeah.
然后，当然，你知道的，我们有休克阻断剂（shock blocker）。嗯哼。所以有很多额外的安全措施。好吧，在几个镜头的背景中，你会看到黄色的救生员浮漂。它们靠在一些泳池浮条旁边，但它们是真正的救生设备，你不会相信我们拍摄这些泳池场景时开的安全会议有多夸张。就像史诗级的安全会议，尤其是当他们点燃那张纸的时候。就像是，我们有灯光，我们有水，我们有电线，我们有明火。如果有人觉得累了，我们有救生员
And then, of course, you know, we had the shock blocker. Mm-hmm. So there was a lot of added stuff. Well, in the background of a few shots, you will see yellow lifeguard floaty things. They were leaning up next to some pull noodles, but their actual lifeguard, like, saving devices, you would not believe the safety meeting that went down when we shot these pull scenes. It was like epic safety meeting, Especially when they lit the paper on fire. It was like, we have lights, we have water, we have electrical lines, we have an open flame. If anyone's feeling tired, we have lifeguard
浮标东西。他们一直在指出所有的事。好吧，德怀特醒过来了，他去和安迪谈论艾琳。他试图暗示你犯了个大错误。是的。但安迪没听懂。安迪觉得没关系。如果你想和艾琳约会，你可以和艾琳约会。我和杰西卡在一起。但我确实觉得德怀特埋下了一点怀疑的种子。
booey things. They were pointing everything out all the time. Well, Dwight is going to come to and he's going to go talk to Andy about Aaron. He's trying to imply you're making a big mistake. Yeah. But Andy doesn't get it. Andy's like it's fine. If you want to date Aaron, you can date Aaron. I'm with Jessica. But I do think Dwight planted a little seed of doubt.
那可能已经存在了。是的。我想指出一件事，随着我们接近这一集的尾声。你注意到菲利斯那条漂亮的泳衣裙了吗？是的。她太喜欢它了。我们很喜欢。我们都觉得她穿上它非常好看。
That was maybe already there. Yeah. I wanted to point out one thing as we're coming to the close of this episode. Did you notice Phyllis' beautiful bathing suit dress? Yes. She loved it so much. We loved it. We all thought she looked so pretty in it.
所以我带着她在泳池边拍了一小组合影。你拍了。我当时想，菲利斯，这套衣服太可爱了。我们需要拍张照片留念。我太喜欢这张她的照片了。我会把它发到我们的故事（Stories）里。好吧，大约在这个时候，达里尔受够了。他要下水了。
So I did a little photo shoot with her by the side of the pool. You did. I was like, Phyllis, this outfit is too cute. We need to take a picture of it. I just love this picture of her. I'll put it in our stories. Well, around this time, Darryl's had enough. He's going to get in the water.
他觉得和瓦尔在一起比担心自己的外表更重要。他脱掉了衬衫。他做了一个大大的炸弹跳水（cannonball），瓦尔高兴极了。是的。这就是艾琳游向安迪的时候。你猜她在泳池底部发现了什么。
He decides being with Val is more important than worrying about what he looks like. He takes off his shirt. He does a big cannonball, and Val is totally delighted. Yeah. This is when Erin is going gonna swim up to Andy. Guess what? She found at the bottom of the pool.
订婚戒指。而且她知道这是传家宝，因为它上面有伯纳德家族的印章。这也是安迪觉得，哦，她真的很懂我。她懂我的地方。好吧，罗伯特的参观结束了。他们回到了泳池区。
The engagement ring. And she knows that it's a family heirloom because it has the Bernard family seal on it. And this is another way where Andy's like, oh, she really knows me. She knows me. Well, Robert's tour is complete. They've made it back to the pool area.
吉姆还在试图离开。就在这时，罗伯特环顾四周，他意识到他一直希望在自己家里发生的事情正在发生。是的，人们放飞自我了，在喝酒，在大笑。巴克斯，酒神。
Jim is still trying to leave. And this is when Robert is gonna look around and he is going to realize that this thing that he's wanted to happen in his house all along is happening. Yes, people are loose and they're drinking and they're laughing. Boccus, God of wine.
是的。好吧，在罗伯特环顾四周蒙太奇剪辑时，大家在喝酒，在大笑。巴克斯。酒神。是的。好吧，在罗伯特环顾四周的蒙太奇剪辑时，如果你也很好奇，为什么克里德躺在地上穿着黑色三角泳裤（speedo）戴着金色王冠弹吉他，我和你当时的想法是一模一样的。我根本没注意到这个。
Yes. Well, during the montage when Robert's looking around, and they're drinking and they're laughing. Rockets. Boccus. God of wine. Yes. Well, during the montage when Robert's looking around, if you were also curious, why Creed is laying on the ground playing the guitar in a black speedo wearing a gold crown, I was right there with ya. I did not notice this.
你没看到克里德头上戴着金色王冠吗？没有，我们也没收到关于这事的任何邮件。拜托。至少我没看到。好吧，我当时好奇得不得了。我心想，为什么克里德会有一顶金色王冠？这从哪来的？我看了拍摄剧本，里面有一个被删掉的场景。什么？上面写着：内景，罗伯特的卧室。克里德撬开了罗伯特的保险箱。他找到了一个天鹅绒盒子并小心翼翼地打开了它。里面是一顶王冠。克里德说了下面这番话。
You didn't see Creed wearing a gold crown on his head? No, we didn't get any mail about it either. Come on. Not that I saw. Okay, well, I was incredibly curious. I was like, why does Creed have a gold crown? Where did this come from? I went to the shooting draft and there was a deleted scene. What? It said interior Robert's bedroom. Creed cracks open Robert's safe. He finds a velvet box and carefully opens it. Inside is a crown. Creed says the following.
啊，在这里。克里德拿出一把小折刀，开始从王冠上撬一颗钻石。他把钻石取了下来，不过也留下了王冠。并戴着它出现在罗伯特面前。所以罗伯特会立刻知道他撬开了自己的保险箱。另外，为什么罗伯特会有一顶精致的金色王冠？
Ah, here it is. Creed takes out a pocket knife and begins to pry a diamond from the crown. He took the diamond out and though also kept the crown. And wore it in front of Robert. So Robert would have known immediately that he cracked open his safe. Also, why does Robert have an elaborate gold crown?
这并没有解释。也许那是他世代财富的一部分。支持你的理论。是的，确实如此。好吧，罗伯特看到眼前的景象会兴奋不已。他当着所有员工的面脱掉了所有的衣服，然后跳进泳池游泳。
That was not explained. Maybe that's part of his generational wealth. Support your theory. Yes, it does. Well, Robert's gonna be so excited by what he sees. He's gonna take off all of his clothes in front of all of his employees and he's gonna go swimming.
而且还是仰泳。是的，剧本里特别注明了他游的是仰泳。关于对裆部区域进行模糊处理，标准和实践部门有什么说法吗？哦，是的，女士。当然有。史蒂夫·伯吉斯正如先前所指出的那样首先遇到了。哦，因为你知道的，瑞恩和加比也脱了衣服，
Backstroke, no less. Yes, that was specifically noted in the script that he does a backstroke. Was there anything from standards and practices about the blurred of the crotch area? Oh, yes, lady. There sure was. Steve Burgess gets his first as previously noted. Oh, because you know, Ryan and Gabe also get undressed,
而且还是仰泳。是的，剧本里特别注明了他游的是仰泳。审查部门对裆部模糊处理有什么要求吗？哦，有的，女士。确实有。如前所述，史蒂夫·伯吉斯是第一个。哦，因为你知道，瑞恩和加布也脱了衣服，
you get into the pool, and of course, you all know, they were not actually naked. No one was naked. They were wearing nude shorts. However, Steve Burgess said they all had to sign nudity waivers, nonetheless, but Steve said we also got this note from standards and practices. As previously noted,
你走进泳池，当然，你们都知道，他们实际上并不是赤身裸体。没有人是赤身裸体的。他们穿着肉色短裤。然而，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，尽管如此，他们都必须签署裸露豁免书，但史蒂夫说我们还收到了来自审查部门的这份便签。如前所述，
please blur all nudity here and throughout. Nothing should be visible through the effect. That was their note on the scene. Okay. I did laugh really hard at how Gabe just falls in with his pants half on his feet. You know, who else loved that? Was Rachel Kay from Denton, Texas. You know what? That was not scripted. Zach couldn't get his pants off. Steve Burgess said that he
请模糊此处及整个过程中的所有裸露画面。通过特效不应该能看到任何东西。那是他们对这个场景的便签。好吧。对于盖布裤子只穿了一半就摔进去的样子，我真的笑了好久。你知道，还有谁喜欢那个吗？是来自德克萨斯州丹顿的雷切尔·凯。你知道吗？那不是剧本里写的。扎克没能把裤子脱下来。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他
improvised that and everyone kind of freaked out because they're like, is he going to be able to swim with his legs bound up like that? But it worked and that's the take we use. It's really funny. Well, that pretty much wraps up Pull Party. No one really wanted to hang around after that. That's right. I mean, Jim drove over some bushes to finally go home. You just like, give me the hell out of here. Well, we did have one final fan question
那是即兴发挥的，大家有点吓坏了，因为他们在想，他双腿被束缚成那样还能游得动吗？但效果很好，我们用的就是那个镜头。这真的很好笑。好吧，泳池派对到此基本就结束了。在那之后真的没有人想逗留。没错。我的意思是，吉姆开车轧过一些灌木丛才终于回了家。你当时就像是，赶紧让我离开这鬼地方吧。好吧，我们确实有一个最后的粉丝问题
from Haley M. In Shawnee, Oklahoma, who said, did the cast get to have a Pull Party behind the scenes? Because that sounds like it could be a lot of fun. who said, did the cast get to have a pool party behind the scenes? Because that sounds like it could be a lot of fun. I wasn't there, Haley, but Angela, I'm imagining that when you wrapped, you all were very happy to get away from the pool. We were done.
来自俄克拉荷马州肖尼市的海莉·M，她问，演员们在幕后有机会举办泳池派对吗？因为听起来这会很有趣。她问，演员们在幕后有机会举办泳池派对吗？因为听起来这会很有趣。我不在场，海莉，但我猜，安吉拉，当你们杀青时，大家一定很高兴能离开那个泳池。我们结束了。
Yeah. We were like, we've been in the pool all day. We're out. There was, however, something going on during the shooting of this episode that was quite fun, which is that the St. Louis Cardinals were in the World Series. And as you know, we had a lot of St. Louis folks on our crew and in our cast, and Ellie Kemper sent in a clip about it. Jenna, I remember the St. Louis Cardinals were in the World Series at the top.
是的。我们当时想，我们在泳池待了一整天。我们撤了。不过，在这个剧集的拍摄过程中发生了一件相当有趣的事，那就是圣路易斯红雀队打进了世界大赛。如你所知，我们的剧组和演员中有很多人来自圣路易斯，艾莉·肯珀为此发来了一段音频。珍娜，我记得圣路易斯红雀队在最开始就打进了世界大赛。
I had this memory of them being in the World Series at the top. I have this memory of them being in the World Series and Phyllis kept sneaking out to the van to listen to the game on the radio. So go think Lewis, go pull party. Okay, that's how my deep thoughts about pool party. Thanks ladies. Well, Steeper just said that in addition to having the game on inside the van,
我对他们打进世界大赛留有最初的记忆。我有他们打进世界大赛的记忆，菲利斯不断偷偷溜到面包车里用收音机听比赛。所以加油圣路易斯，加油泳池派对。好吧，这就是我对泳池派对的深刻感悟。谢谢女士们。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，除了在面包车里面看比赛，
they also had it on a TV outside. Lady, this game was huge. This was the St. Louis Cardinals versus the Texas Rangers. And you know Lee is from Texas. Yes. Well, my son was one month old. My sister came out to visit. She brought all kinds of Cardinals gear for my son to wear.
他们在外面也放了一台电视。女士，这场比赛太盛大了。这是圣路易斯红雀队对阵德克萨斯游骑兵队。你知道李是德克萨斯人。是的。嗯，我儿子当时一个月大。我姐姐来看望我们。她带了各种红雀队的装备给我儿子穿。
And Lee and I had an agreement where we either had to alternate brought all kinds of Cardinals gear for my son to wear. And Lee and I had an agreement where we either had to alternate the St. Louis Cardinals 1Z and the Texas Rangers 1Z, or he had to wear a little bit of each team. So listen, Game 6 of that World Series is epic, because of David Freeze. I won't go on and on, but oh my gosh, first of all, he ties it up, and then he has a walk-off homer in the 11th inning for them to win that game, which they needed to win in order to get to the 7th game. For the 7th game of the World Series,
我和李有个协议，我们要么轮流带红雀队的连体衣和游骑兵队的连体衣，要么他每个队的都穿一点。所以听着，那届世界大赛的第六场比赛简直太史诗级了，因为大卫·弗里斯。我不会喋喋不休地说个没完，但天哪，首先，他扳平了比分，然后在第十一局打出一记再见全垒打，让他们赢得了那场比赛，他们必须赢得这场比赛才能进入第七场。对于世界大赛的第七场，
I sneaked two cardinal socks on my son's feet. And the cardinal's won, and I think that's why. I love Arlington Stadium. We would go there and watch ball games. It's beautiful. You're making me want to go to a baseball game. I know. Well, listen everybody, that was pool party,
我悄悄给我儿子的脚上套了两只红雀队的袜子。然后红雀队赢了，我想这就是原因。我喜欢阿灵顿球场。我们过去经常去那里看球赛。它太美了。你让我很想去看一场棒球比赛。我知道。好吧，听着各位，那是泳池派对，
but before we leave, I think we need to have a birthday party. What? Because Angela Kinsey, we are recording this episode right before we go on our summer break. Your birthday is June 25th, and we're gonna be on vacation for your birthday. I hope I did a good job as party coordinator this time. I can't believe you remembered this.
但在我们离开之前，我想我们需要举办一个生日派对。什么？因为安吉拉·金斯利，我们在我们去过暑假之前录制这集节目。你的生日是6月25日，而我们要去度假庆祝你的生日。我希望这次我作为派对协调员做得很好。真不敢相信你还记得这个。
I also can't believe I almost forgot to pick you up this morning. I know. I've been driving Jenna to work. We've been carpooling. It's been so fun. I've really enjoyed it because of my broken shoulder. And this morning I was on autopilot
我也真不敢相信我今天早上差点忘了去接你。我知道。我一直在开车送珍娜上班。我们一直在拼车。这太有趣了。由于我的肩膀骨折，我真的很享受这段时光。今天早上我处于自动驾驶状态，
and I just got on the freeway and went the wrong way. I was so worried how am I going to hide the birthday stuff because you're driving me to work. So that's why I had a giant bag with me today. You didn't ask thank goodness. Here's your present, Ange. You're so sweet. I can't believe this. This is so cute. Oh my gosh. I didn't do my hair or anything today. I know. I thought of that.
我直接上了高速公路，走错了方向。我当时太担心了，因为你要开车送我上班，我该怎么把生日的东西藏起来呢。这就是为什么我今天带了一个巨大的袋子。谢天谢地你没问。这是给你的礼物，安吉。你太贴心了。真不敢相信。这太可爱了。天哪。我今天没弄头发什么的。我知道。我想到了这一点。
You said I didn't have time to get ready. I'm gonna show up in my pajamas and I was like, well, we might be taking some pictures. Wait, you got me a succulent. Of course. Ah, wait, I got to fish it out. I didn't get you any birthday sweet treat because I know Josh does that. You have plenty of sweet treats. Oh, the pen is mine. Sorry. Oh, this is so cute.
你说我没有时间准备。我要穿着睡衣出现，而我的反应是，嗯，我们可能要拍一些照片。等等，你送了我一株多肉植物。当然。啊，等等，我得把它掏出来。我没有给你买任何生日甜点，因为我知道乔什会做那些。你已经有很多甜点啦。哦，这支笔是我的。对不起。哦，这太可爱了。
I love a succulent. And you got me something and a, you got me a little piece of, what is it? You guys, it's a hummingbird necklace. It is the gold hummingbird. It is so freaking cute. I love it so much. I'm putting it on right now.
我喜欢多肉植物。你还送了我一个，一个，你送了我一小块，是什么来着？伙计们，这是一条蜂鸟项链。它是金色蜂鸟。太可爱了。我太喜欢了。我现在就要戴上它。
Hummingbirds and succulents. Equal Angela, and we've got a card out there for you too. Everyone's signed it. I love it. Thank you guys. Aw, happy birthday, Angela, happy pool party. Thank you, Steve Burgess, and Ellie Kemper, and Amina, and Matt Flynn, and all of you guys
蜂鸟和多肉植物。等于安吉拉，外面也有一张卡片给你的。大家都签名了。我太喜欢了。谢谢你们。哦，生日快乐，安吉拉，泳池派对快乐。谢谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、艾莉·肯珀、阿米娜、马特·弗林，以及所有写信来提出问题和评论的你们
for writing in with your questions and comments. We love you guys. Oh, oh, lady, wait. What? One more thing before we go. This episode is gonna be airing in August. August? Yes, so we should remind everyone about our live show that's gonna be in Toronto on September
大家。我们爱你们。哦，哦，女士，等等。什么？在我们离开之前还有一件事。这集节目将在八月份播出。八月份？是的，所以我们应该提醒大家我们在多伦多的现场演出将在九月
21st as part of the Just For Laughs Festival. Oh yes, we are so excited. So excited. We had such a blast at Just For Laughs in Vancouver, and we can't wait to do it again. Yes, and tickets are still available. I'll put a link in Office Ladies' Pod Stories. just for last and Vancouver, and we can't wait to do it again! Yes, and tickets are still available! I'll put a link in Office Ladies' Pod Stories. Great! Okay, now we can go!
21日举行，作为“头号人物”喜剧节的一部分。哦，是的，我们太兴奋了。太兴奋了。我们在温哥华的“头号人物”喜剧节上玩得太开心了，我们迫不及待地想再来一次。是的，门票仍在出售中。我会在《办公室女士》播客故事中放一个链接。太棒了！好吧，现在我们可以走了！
Bye! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Scher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy,
再见！再见！感谢收听《办公室女士》！《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、詹妮弗·谢尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，
and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡树》。你这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。